e
e e
since we're talking I think we will
start the
[Laughter]
committee so Senator gray do you want to
bring up
your uh the senator gray would you like
to bring up your point from last time no
uh it was a a general comment about turn
on your microphone please thank it was a
general comment about how much detail we
should go into when we're talking about
modifying a fund and since we're not the
policy committee I would like to see us
maybe make a suggestion or two but that
the policy committee ought to be the one
that says yes we want to do this or no
we don't want to do that that kind of
thing just a general comment keep us out
of the weeds okay at representative
alies thank you on the reason this was
put
in uh this way was after many years of
experimentation uh because the policy
committees would not look at their
dedicated funds and they were putting in
bills that said said that they were
going to do something that was already
in a dedicated fund and
uh and so I think
that we have a responsibility to address
to the policy committee that we think
this might make this dedicated fund work
or or and in the case of we think this
fund should go away because it doesn't
seem to be doing anything we could put
it in the bill and have the policy
committee show
up yeah okay well we'll we'll before you
yes represent Senator Grant yeah re
bottle
uh the when it's all in one bill the
bill isn't going to go to all of the
policy committees that may need to go
okay
so you
know representative only if if we took
in some of these that we thought should
go to the policy committee and actually
wrote them as separate bills you know
coming out of this committee then we
could assure they went to the policy
committee before they came came back to
a finance committee again I I think that
there's ways we can do it you and I have
been on this committee what eight or 10
years now
so
amen so so I may be I may be only half
but you know eight or 10 years of
experience I think you know gives me a
little bit of right to to say a few
things that can I answer on I that that
that is a good solution if we think
there is a specific change that ought to
be made that we write the bill and then
send it to them yeah so so I think when
we get to the bill stage you can Senator
gray or anyone else can certainly say
let's make this one a separate bill and
I don't see any problem with that I'm in
general in favor
of one one issue bills um more so than
the Senate seems to be but anyway
all right let's start with who's first
today
Dr um is that right no I think it
was oh it is Dr now yeah they it's it's
slightly out of order in this book
but yeah anyways the agenda and the and
the spreadsheet are slightly out of
order but we'll start with with you
thank you good morning thank you lindsy
steep commissioner Department of Revenue
Administration with me is Shelley gerano
business administrator happy to be here
today with you um dris has two dedicated
funds the first is the municipal
officers and employees Education and
Training
fund we use this fund um we collect
money when we provide trainings to
assessing officials Town officials hold
on a second commissioner we we we always
like to open our books to the right page
so I I will try to find that it's 284
284 thank you very much and the clerk
needs to write all your names oh
okay all
right okay
are we ready uh commissioner step
and okay ready and Shelly s h e l l e
y Gano oh
gosh g e r l l a r NE Au I was do that
okay good job and Shel is the business
administrator great all right thank you
commissioner go ahead okay so our first
dedicated fund is the municipal officers
and employees training fund um this fund
collects money from participants when a
small nominal fee when we provide
various training opportunities to
assessing officials Town official
officials Municipal officials that money
is then used to provide Refreshments for
long classes provide hard copy training
materials Etc we cannot keep more than
$5,000 in that fund so anything over
$5,000 that we have collected and has
have not spent will lapse at the end of
the year so that's why you will see that
in fiscal year 203 the beginning balance
was
$5,000 um we collected just over
$5,000 spent
$3,660 but the ending balance again goes
back to the 5,000 so it's just a fund
that we use for materials when providing
trainings we provide a number of
trainings over the course of the Year
everything from assessment review mini
courses to multiple State statutes
courses to Tax Collector's workshops Etc
rep representative Janan so the the U
other uses in this case
1405 um what what is so you have to
always get back to 5,000 how does that
get used
up that will lapse back to the to the
general fund the excess over 5,000 and
that 1405 is the excess that went back
to the okay thank
you so why don't numbers in the book and
on the page
match I don't know actually um because
it looks like the the book only goes to
fiscal year 23 but um the memorandum we
provided also includes 24 so right the
the new book for 24 will have your new
numbers and I think it's just a
presentation difference I think that the
memo is not reflecting the laps in the
same way that the book is but the book
gets you back to the 5,000 so I think
it's just a presentation oh I see so
right because okay the in the book The
Other column is the lasts correct
correct I see
okay and and you suspended um these kind
classes during the pandemic is that what
happened we held the classes online as
much as possible but obviously those
classes don't have the printed materials
don't have the refreshments provided so
the cost in those years um were lower
and you can see our Revenue was lower in
those years as well we didn't charge um
as much as we normally would would but
yes that's the the 21 and 22 are direct
result of the pandemic any other
questions representative
Al thank you uh how long has that 5,000
laps been in and does it create a
problem the 5,000 laps has been in as
long as I'm aware and I don't think it
creates a problem um that seems like the
right amount okay thank
you all right let's go out to the next
one okay now page
285 this is the revenue information
management system fund also known as the
rims um Debt Service so when the
department received a
$3,160 th000 capital appropriation to
fund our new Revenue information
technology system or management system a
portion of that was to be paid back the
debt on that the principal and interest
was to be paid back with additional
Revenue that the system would
provide and the way that happens is per
statute the
Dr um with das's help uh transfers up to
$4 million of Revenue uplift every year
into this dedicated fund and then this
fund is used to pay the debt service
um we provide a memo every year to um
the capital project overview committee
and the House and Senate Ways and Means
committees um relative to our
calculation of the revenue uplift um in
all of the last three years so fiscal
year 22 fiscal year 23 and fiscal year
24 we did generate Revenue uplift in
excess of the $4 million um but we only
trans ER up to that cap of 4 million we
will make these transfers into this
dedicated fund until the fund reaches or
until we have transferred $40
million um that was the estimated
principal and interest that would needed
need to be paid on the debt that was to
be serviced by this Revenue uplift to
date in fiscal years 21 to 24 we have
deposited um just under 14 .2 million so
we have just over 25.8 million to go
assuming that we meet that $4 million
cap every year we will be doing this for
seven more
years all right let me
ask if we're in debt here and we have a
balance in this fund why don't we pay
off the debt quicker than we would
otherwise so the debt services to is
provided to us by um treasury so those
are the numbers that provided to us and
I think that the timing of that and
those Amounts is based on the bonds that
were issued to service um to originally
fund the system and so the amounts that
we pay back are the principle and
interest that are coming due on those
bonds um as we move through the length
of the bond
period so maybe they're not callable or
whatever is that I yes okay
representative Jen again well I was just
wondering where the ending balance keeps
going up is is 4 million going in each
year too much should it be 3 million is
that going to is that ending balance
going to just keep going up if so then
it does four million make
sense that would I think be a question
for treasury as they have the full Debt
Service schedule we have asked them
multiple times to provide us with the
schedule but they have not done so um so
we only have what needs to be paid in
the next bium because that goes into our
budget but I do think the way the bonds
were they were not issued all at once
they were issued over a period of time
as we Dr needed to pay the invoices for
the capital project so I suspect there
will be a bit of like a bell curve where
there will be years where the expenses
are more than the 1.7 million that we've
seen to date um the up to $4 million a
year and a total of 40 million um those
amounts were done in conjunction with
treasury based on what they anticipated
The Debt Service schedule to be so that
would never leave us hopefully without
enough money in the fund to pay the debt
service but shouldn't produce um an
excess for long periods of time because
this money is coming right out of the
general fund into this dedicated fund
okay thank
you other yes represent Ming yeah what I
don't understand is this on this 40
million
stays that in act that is it isn't being
taken away by treasury to pay
existing uh Co Bond
calls it will pay the service the
principal in interest on the bonds that
were used to fund the rims
project um I guess at the end when the
40 million has been entered into the
fund we will stop putting money into it
but the debt will there'll be debt that
will need to be paid beyond that point
in time we will be paying debt beyond
the seven years we're estimating it'll
take us seven years to fully fund the 40
million treasury will continue or we
will continue to pay the debt beyond
that point and then once the debt is
fully paid off I imagine the excess in
the dedicated fund at that point would
go back to the general fund or we would
work with the legislature Treasury and
Das to essentially end this fund I'm
going to I'm going to call the treasurer
and ask for details on the
characteristics of those fonds
and
um what's a would it make sense to to
transfer this fund to the
treasury that's an
interesting so when this was originally
set up um Dr had the dedicated fund to
pay the debt in our budget and treasury
because they had the debt service
schedule they had the payment of the
principal and interest in their budget
the treasurer asked last year during the
last budget session to move the debt
service to our budget so we now have the
dedicated fund and then we also have the
payment of the principal and
interest however I don't have the full
debt schedule so I only have what
treasury has provided which has been a
bium at a time so they are both here at
Dr yeah but I still lack visibility into
oh so you write checks to the bond
holders treasury does out of our account
I see so all right well I'll I'll call
them and get more details I all right
other questions from the committee no
thank you very much
commissioner oh yes sorry uh Senator
Rose um is this going to be like the
mmis system which is going to cost us $2
million a year or whatever in
forever I hope not not um so I can give
you some more context so the rim system
was implemented fully implemented over a
course of three years it was on time on
budget through the pandemic which was a
pretty remarkable feat I think um then
through um additional funding with arpa
money we recently upgraded the system to
the most recent version and that will go
live uh the first weekend in October so
we are fully up todate with the solution
that's provided by our vendor fast
Enterprises we through our operating
budget we will fund hardware and
software maintenance and support going
forward in the next budget we will be
moving to a Cloud solution so we will no
longer hopefully moving to a Cloud
solution so we will no longer have
hardware and that will be fully
operationalized in our budget so there
will be no more additional Capital fund
funding that we will need and my goal is
to evaluate going forward the various
version upgrades that are provided by
the vendor and make a decision at each
version upgrade whether or not it is
fatuous for New Hampshire to upgrade I
will say it is a commercial
off-the-shelf software it is used in
most other um Departments of Revenue
across the country however most of those
departments have an income tax a
personal income tax and a sales tax so I
don't imagine that we will do every
version upgrade there will be features
that will be added that just won't be
applicable to us and so we will evaluate
kind of moving forward what upgrades
look like for us but I can say as of the
first weekend in October we are on the
most current system version of the
system and so I don't anticipate large
costs um associated with this in the
next few years representative all me
thank you can you remember
approximately how many million
we you this system H over the 4 million
has provided to the general
fund yes in the three years it's
been
Surplus sure so in fiscal year 24 we
generated 14.5 million in Revenue uplift
and only transfer the 4 million so you
have 105 million
there um in fiscal year
23 we generated a total of 9 million but
only transferred the four so you have
another 5 million there so that's 15
million and then
in fiscal
year
22 we were very close to the 4 million
exactly and then fiscal year 21 we
didn't reach the 4 million so over the
course we've generated an additional 15
million that has not been transferred
roughly what do you mean by that what is
revenue uplift great question so Revenue
uplift occurs in a few different ways
and the approach that that we've taken
to identifying this is revenue that we
believe would not have been able to have
been recognized using our old outdated
system so the first example is remind to
pay letters so in our old system we sent
you a tax notice if you did not respond
to that tax notice after 80 Days you
went to collections and an individual
collector would make a phone call start
mailing letters Etc because of
Automation in the new system we send you
a tax notice and then in 30 days we send
you a reminder that you had received the
tax notice any money that's paid between
that reminder to pay letter and the 80
days when it would typically go to
collections we're counting that as
Revenue uplift because that's
functionality that we didn't have before
it certainly saves our collector's time
because this money this debt isn't being
sent to them so that generated a total
of 5.4 million doll in fiscal 24 and
then the um another area where we have
Revenue uplift is through the use of
federal tax information from the IRS the
IRS has very stringent requirements
ments around the security of the
information and our old system did not
meet the security requirements necessary
to really use the IRS information in the
most efficient manner so with the new
system being fully secured meeting all
of the security requirements we can
better utilize that information that
generated $7 million last year and the
last is we now allow taxpayers through
our online portal to um do essentially
automated payment plans they can easily
enter into a payment plan if it meets
certain requirements that we've put in
place it does not have to go for
approval um and so that's an efficiency
certainly and that generated just under
2 million last year all right thank you
so at the re I I'm uh in danger of
getting Senator
gray by getting too much detail here so
let's go on to Department of Information
Technology thank you
all
right all right so this is Page what
page page one page
one I don't know how we got that honor
but so good morning Mr chair um and
members of the committee um for the
record uh my name is Dennis goule I'm
the commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology olog and with me
today is is our Director of Finance Rose
Curry um we're here to talk about our uh
our Telecom dedicated fund and I I'll
I'll go over the um you can see in in in
the letter the table a and and the fund
balances and things like that I'm going
to go over kind of in in as much
layman's terms as I can what the fund is
is what its purpos is and what its
financial status is uh now and what we
expect it to be over the years um
essentially the the Telecom fund is is
covering really um three major areas one
is the voice
Communications uh for the Executive
Branch the other is the uh is networking
and that's two parts so I'm bre you know
of the three parts there two of them are
networking one is what we call wide area
network that connects the you know 400
or so locations that we're servicing
around the state um anything from a do
shed to a you know to a liquor store to
a you know to a DHHS uh district office
or or any other district office from
from an agency so there um and then the
other network is the one that we um that
sits inside the uh agency locations that
our employees connect
to um essentially this was designed so
that we over collect over time a little
bit just just enough to keep the the
equipment
dated um and and supportable and and
what that means really is that because
uh of many of the compliance
requirements we have to upgrade the
equipment as soon as pretty close to
when it's end of life or when it's end
of support because we will no longer get
cyber security um updates for said
equipment so it's really important that
we keep that equipment um uh up to date
and and so we strive to to have the uh
particularly the network equipment in
our
locations um in a you know it's about a
six to sevene window that it has to be
replaced
um we we have a rate card that that is
part of the the budget planning process
each bium during the nine plus years
I've been here the rate card has stayed
almost the same during that time so it's
it's although you see other parts of my
budget uh have gone up over time we've
kept the rate card pretty flat uh during
that period in fact uh we expect it to
go down um in in this banial budget
planning um so so you look at the the
growth of the fund and it looks like
it's it's started to grow a lot and that
is true and there's a and it it it turns
out to be a performant and reliable
Network it's a musthave so um
additionally we're in the trans
transition today between the kind of old
style telepan and the fully converged
telefony so what's old style telephony
you know you got your phone on your desk
you have one wire that goes to that
phone uh the the the more modern
telefony would be uh in fact I I've got
an example of it right now I have two
phone numbers on this my state phone one
of them is my mobile number and the
other's my desk number I don't have a
desk phone anymore so we're we have some
expensive that we're accumulating um in
the millions uh in to um leverage that
transition over time as well and um and
lastly this uh this arpa money that
transitioned the network in another uh
few years we're three years into that
project now and another few years we'll
be in the maintenance of of all of that
equipment and we'll start the process
all over again our so so I feel like
that although it looks like we may be
over collecting here I don't feel that's
the case I feel like we're being pretty
responsible with with the this funding
because we're really striving to keep
the long-term
collections um somewhat close as close
as possible to the long-term
requirements of the state in the areas
that we're covering with this fund and
uh the the other thing I other thing I
really like about this model it's it's a
small part part of my budget but one of
the things I really like about it is it
it transitions from a what could be a
really bumpy model like imagine I'm
coming to you every six years and asking
for $34.5 million I don't have to do
that here I collect I keep a pretty flat
rate card for the agencies and then we
don't have those big um Financial
impacts every few years uh so that
concludes my formal testimony uh happy
to answer any question from the
committee thank you
repres Senator Rosen thank you I'm just
curious how you get two phone numbers on
one phone because well well actually
Verizon tells me I can't do that I
misspoke I actually have three phone
numbers on this but but and my I
actually have two phone numbers on my
personal phone because um so there's a
couple ways one is you you can get two
phone numbers on the more newer phones
because they have these the the Sim
which is that
yeah eim so if you had a physical Sim
and an eim that's two numbers uh on my
personal phone I have two numbers
because I have the number that came from
Verizon I also have my old home number
so I don't have a phone at home anymore
my home number rings on my personal
phone because I got I ported it over to
an app I'm I'm being geeky here but
that's how I did I ported it over to an
app and I have the app on the phone and
so somebody calls my old personal home
number it rings on my personal cell
phone okay well we can take this
softline I'm happy to help you with that
so does the committee have any questions
about the dedicated
fund all right I'll ask you so um this
fund covers not just equipment which
would make sense to me because
effectively you're depreciating that
equipment and you want to store money to
to replace it but it also has salaries
for a considerable number of people
right over 15 fulltime correct so does
that make sense or should that simp be
budgeted and not part of this fund um
well you know it's I I haven't really
thought about that it's just been how
it's been and you know I inherited the
fund from Department of Safety I think
in uh 2016 or 17 and at the time they
you know they were funding the staff
that supports the network and the
telepan so it really you know if you
look at it it's a it's a nice bundle it
says here's what we're here's what we're
spending on that so certainly we're not
over collecting on salaries um we're you
know we're just looking at that as as um
not an accumulation thing so the
accumulating part of the fund really is
for the equipment and and stuff that is
ephemeral and the uh and then the the
salaries and benefits I think makes
sense in the sense that they are aligned
with that
mission of the four to five million
annual expenses how much of that is
salary and
benefit 15 people well that's a that's a
question I didn't prepare for so I we
can we can get back to that with ASAP
with that answer but I I don't have that
on the top I guess I'm guessing it's
less than half but I'm not sure yeah I'm
guessing you know it's it's they're
they're fairly High you know for State
uh they're fairly highly compensated
because they're Network engineers and
things like that so I'm but I'd hate to
throw out a number now that isn't
correct so maybe you can get us that as
an as a separate column or something
okay thank you other
representative thank you I think related
to this uh who decides
on on the spending in this dedicated
fund is it just you and executive
Council or does the the do the finance
committees have a say in this good
question um so we we uh we have an appro
A banal appropriation
um which is um you know been been been
around $8 or $9 million a year over the
time I've been here and then if we have
extra expenditures beyond that
appropriation like a large expenditure
say to do the the data center Network
ring that we're going to have to be
doing soon we would then take that to
the executive Council and they would e
approve it or not but but I've never um
gone to fiscal committee for that uh
it's interesting because that's the only
situation where I don't go to the Joint
fiscal
committee other
questions all right thank you very much
commissioner yeah if you could get us
that the salary equipment breakdown
that'd be great we'll have it to you
today okay all right so next we have the
office of professional licensure and
certification I think
oops a new
commissioner welcome thank you so much
so good morning for the record um Deana
jurus executive director of oplc uh if
you will indulge me uh I've been on the
job about 10 days can can you slow down
a bit and spell name and SP okay Diana D
EA n n
a jurus
jur i u s
all I all I was planning to say was if
you'll indulge me I've been on the job
about 10 days and I I'd like to uh defer
my time to my director of operations
Heather Kelly uh just to speak to the
two dedicated funds if that's okay with
the
committee hold on they're on you're
looking for page 69 page 69 thank
yes and I forgot to bring my book please
you forgot your book oh okay I had to
forget something I spent 10 hours
yesterday after I got back from conquer
oh on this wow that's what I mean by
slave driver I
see I I didn't realize okay uh page 69
and I'll share my
book well we I do
have figure where I left the
page the page
uh here it is this one
yeah more up to right all right thank
you very much Miss Kelly uh good morning
uh Heather Kelly director of operations
for oplc oplc has two dedicated
and expenditures for the boards uh the
dedicated non-aps fund was reestablished
in uh
2023 so the lapsing funds that you see
underneath other sources were the funds
that used to lapse to the general fund
uh oplc uh is able to collect up to $5
million in that dedicated fund once it
reaches $5 million the agency is then
required to readjust fees uh the agency
is statutorily not allowed to collect
more than
125% the agency's goal is to have all
boards collect 100% of their expenditure
so that no boards are subsidizing other
boards the
yep representative slow slow down a bit
sorry I don't think any of this is in
there
okay collect more than statutorily we're
not allowed to collect more more than
125% right yeah it used to be
right all the extra would lapse to the
general fund but because we sort of
broke them off into a separate fund then
uh their goal is now to be 100% right
and not collect not overcharge uh
professionals so that is correct go
ahead yes
the the second fund is our Prof let's
let's wait let's see if we have
questions on on this
one Senator rosenan thank you
so are all of your
boards now just collecting
100% of their expenses in fees currently
we have boards that are collecting less
than 100% uh and then we do have boards
that are grossly collecting more than
the 100% and subsidizing the other
boards we are currently in the process
of evalu Val ating those figures and we
will be adjusting fees
accordingly yes follow could you give us
an idea how many are under collecting
and how many are over collecting I would
say about half of it's about split so
the larger boards are collecting more
revenue and subsidizing so the larger
boards would be medicine Pharmacy um and
then some of the smaller boards are
collecting less than 100% but we have
those figures previously for analysis
that we did a few years ago and we can
certainly get that analysis over to you
uh but we do have those figures from
2022 thank you you're
welcome yes uh represent wer is the
reason for the smaller boards under
collecting is because there's so few
getting those licenses I remember you
had at sometimes as few as 40 people
with a license correct the agency does a
cost allocation based on number of
lenses so that can sometimes drive up
their or drive down some would overpay
based on the number um and so it depends
on the number of lenses that's how we
evaluate that figure yes because some of
those smaller boards it would be a
ridiculous cost thousands of dollars a
year for a license correct and we then
we look at that and evaluate it and then
adjust the fee appropriately so they
aren't paying thousands of dollarss
and I think the reason that we put all
of them in your board or your commission
was because you could balance those
things or you had the smaller ones that
otherwise we would have to charge
ridiculous prices for a license so I'm
not I'm not upset by that because I
think that was designed thank
you other question representative Al
yeah I remember quite some time ago
actually we redid All of the small
medical boards in Ways and Means before
it was taken away from us and given
somewhere else um the on there I think
it was assistance to optometrists that
had their own group and they were being
paid obviously a lot less than anybody
else do you did that go into the
calculation too and the The Midwives may
have been a problem
too in that a number of factors uh we
take in ly counts additionally we have
taken into enforcement counts uh number
of complaints that are brought in and so
that we can properly allocate that cost
across all boards as some boards do not
generate as many enforcement complaints
as others so we have uh expanded the
analysis
appropriately yeah and you dumped
out uh the um
board for manufactured housing entirely
I believe we still have the board of
manufacturer you do yes oh good are you
maintaining the spreadsheet uh the uh um
what do you call it the
website because that was extremely
important to not having that problem
resurface
again I think I may may be able to
clarify so there were two separate
functions there's the board for the
installers of manufactured housing that
board still exists at the oplc because
it is a a licensing function for the
installers okay there additionally there
was a complaint board yes that was
housed at the
oplc that was that board was removed but
I believe and Heather can correct me the
function remains still with the office
although
yes that that's that's how I will leave
it so there is still a process and the
collection of complaints to the office
but there's no board that does those
similarly that I don't I don't have a
special board for complaints for any
other licensing board it comes to the
office through the enforcement process
but that is a newer change so that that
actual functionality on the ground is is
still um being developed within the
office so is is that what you were
referring to the complaint board I could
get clarity uh there was a website which
put up the results of resolution of
complaints and that website allowed
people in manufactured housing to go and
and the owners of it to go to the
website and find out for that particular
circumstance they had worked themselves
out of a
job because they had answered just about
every question you could have about
uh communal
living and um and but they they could go
to that and see what the board had
decided was the best way to handle this
and then gone to the opposite party and
said
look oh and and they would fix it
themselves yeah I think we can if that
no longer exists then we will probably
have a problem in 20 years unless all
manufactured housing boards outside of
of the um Community Loan Fund uh
disappear I I believe that one of the
bills vetoed by the governor had to do
with the board of manufactured housing
oh really and so I think that'll come up
on veto day so that that that bill that
was vetoed was specifically there it was
to create several advisory boards that
are current that are currently licensing
boards so that would be the the
installers so the veto was the Bill had
proposed to make the installers
licensing board and Advisory Board
within the
office um that had passed the
legislature and has been VTO by the
governor so I guess in a few weeks you
will take that up that is still again
separate from the complaint that that
you're speaking of and I we definitely
can look into what I'm sure those
decisions could be integrated into our
website where we have other enforcement
actions or other decisions that were
made um I can't confidently say they
solved all the problems I think there
were a number of challenges as for why
they were not meeting why complaints
were not getting to them um but yes
we're working on establishing the new
process and I I I think your your point
is well taken about having those
decisions live somewhere on our website
y thank you other questions about this
dedicated fund no okay let's go on
oh oh oh no no you already answered that
at the beginning what sources on they
are their lapses to the general right go
ahead uh the second uh dedicated find
sorry could I just I just turn represent
and I put the things on here on just uh
to let you know the um SB 409 was
actually HB 409
uh if anyone wants to look for
it and I guess that was the main thing I
had thank
you go ahead okay uh the second uh
dedicated fund is for our professional
health program for uh our typ right now
for our medical boards this fund is used
uh for uh
the health boards for anyone that is
impaired or has substance abuse issues
uh they can
self-report uh to us and then or through
the enforcement process will be referred
to this program the um
account has been showing in the negative
the agency prior to me was collecting a
fee that didn't cover the cost we've
since raised it
twice um this final adjustment should
now be covering the fund moving
forward uh this is contracted with the
New Hampshire professionals health
program at a cost of
86,87
uh
year so why is this a separate fund and
not part of your main fund this is used
exclusively just for that contract
um there is an RSA 310 that requires us
to have this dedicated fund for this
specific purpose okay uh Senator Ros
thank you I have a couple of
questions um
the topics of health conditions covered
by this fund have
expanded over the time I've been in the
legislature used to be alcohol and drug
use and now
includes cognitive decline so um it's
expanded a bit but what I've heard is
that lower paid health professionals and
I'm specifically thinking of like
lnas really can't afford the
out-of-pocket costs of
treatment um and my understanding is
that this program really is monitoring
it doesn't it doesn't provide treatment
for any of these issues so I guess my
question is has your agency
considered variable fees so that and it
not everybody is paying
$28 fee for a
license
which hits someone making $11 an hour
harder than some orthopedic surgeon
making
$800,000 a year I just wonder if we
could do do
maybe a better job with this incredibly
important program because we don't want
to lose these licensed professionals we
want them to get
recovery kids stay with it and I just
wonder where your agency is
on fitting the fees to the ability yes
uh we have proposed variable fees to all
the boards indicating in
uh professionals at the higher levels
apn's RN's doctors even in the
electricians groups when they're master
electrician
Master to pay more than the apprentices
or the lnas so we have proposed that to
the boards uh and we will be looking
into that additionally we are looking
for grant money to offset the LNA cost
as
well you're
welcome so is this fee up to you or is
it is there a board that decides it this
fee is up to the agency based on the
contracted price so that we can cover
the price so you
could exceed to um Senator rosen's
request right away if you wanted to yeah
would have to go through the rul making
process but yes we could adjust the fee
all
right and so you plan to do so is that
we are considering adjusting fees
commissioner I I guess my question was
uh did you mean the fee specifically
that is for this fund or licensing fees
in general this fund this F okay so a
different question than licensing fees I
understand it's
$28 added to the licensing Fe but it
falls differently
upon different kinds of licenses $8 per
okay is this $28 a year is that what
we're talking about or $28 every two
years every two
years okay represent Welling yeah and
and so the the
$28 is something everybody
pays everyone pays for any board that is
enrolled in the program
yes so there are other fees for their
license in general correct lnas
currently pay $63 that is the $28 per
PHP fee along with their licensing fee I
see okay so I think Senator rosenal has
a good point here yeah all right
thank
you all right yeah thank you sen other
questions yeah Senator gray that was the
one
I yes I I have some one myself so yeah
go ahead Senator gray back on page
68 back on page 68 we have another fund
there's a note down there that says
we're going to make modifications to it
I've lost track of it so I don't know
why we're not talking about it here so
back to you guys that's the real estate
appraisers board fund that you can speak
to the repeal that was repealed uh in
2023 and also on that note down there it
says that you're going to request a new
fund for investigation or something what
where are we on
that last paragraph before the signature
part right book reflects the submission
that was made last year um I don't know
this wasn't submitted um so
we we did not create a dedicated fund
for enforcement it may have predated you
I don't know how it might have been a
her predecessor but we can if you're
going to do it I'd like to to know
before we write our report so I don't
think you have any plans to request any
new dedicated funds that we know of so
we won't worry about it unless you get
back to us I I wonder if that was a
request before the entire office had a
dedicated fund if that the reason I ask
is that the transfer of the stuff from
the assessing Standards Board to you
guys apparently has not gone as smoothly
as I would have hoped okay and in fact I
don't even know if the new
board associated with you guys is up and
running and and fully staffed and all
that yet and so just I'm sensitive when
I see things that uh that deal with real
estate and the division between Dr and
you
guys yeah so Heather can speak to the
fees uh specifically I can say actually
that the certification of assessor board
is meeting tomorrow morning so it it is
up and running it is staffed uh
commissioner Steph and I will both be
there
um myself to introduce myself so that
that is um operating and I and I think
the there were a few bills over a few
years back and forth of moving all of
that over leaving just the certification
so the lure piece with the office but
leaving other parts of it with Dr so
that that was a policy decision so um we
just have the certification piece but
that is operational so and then the fee
piece Heather can speak to so the fee as
uh we generate uh we take in the federal
portion of the fee so instead of having
a dedicated fund the agency has an
account where we deposit those funds
into so that we can properly track those
as those are not our funds as we are
invoiced by the federal government to
pay out those funds so we do have those
designated separately so that we can
distinguish and pay appropriately and
make sure we're generating the correct
amount thank you you're
welome so the thing I wanted to talk to
you about was um on Tuesday we met with
the Department of educ met Department of
Education I'm sorry on Monday yeah on
Monday we met with the Department of
Education for some reason I think today
is Thursday that's my problem all right
um and they have an they have a fund uh
dedicated fund for the board of lure of
interpreters for the de and heart of
hearing and so we discussed that this
board and this fund might be better
handled by
oplc
because it has annual revenues of
$30,000 plus and annual expenses of
about
seven okay so so they are not at all
balanced and it it now has a it's got a
growing balance in this fund now up to$
$228,000
so you know I I was it it occurred to me
that maybe you could handle this in a
better way um I can I can speak very
briefly to that not from my tenure in
the office but from my time in other
various roles in the legislative and
executive branches um there was some
discussion about that so there are a few
still existing certification or
licensure functions that are not with
the office that are still with other um
various agencies that being one of them
obviously teachers in general is another
one that's with the Department of
Education
and um I believe there's um security
agents uh that are still at the
department of safety I think because
there's firearm safety and certification
that that policy decision has been to
leave it there so there was some
discussion about the interpreters board
specifically should that slide over that
it's just a licenser function and the
enforcement should that slide over to
the office um during a conversation with
stakeholders and I'm happy to talk more
offline if you'd like uh there was not
an appetite for that and so I it was not
moved forward but there there was some
initial discussion about that and it was
met with significant
resistance but if if the legislature
wanted to make that policy decision that
would that being overcharged by a factor
of three or so you know so I I and I
imagine the uh the cost would be very
different within the oplc structure than
education so I'm not sure the 7,000
would hold but also we wouldn't be able
to charge them more than 25% when it
fell in our calculation and um yeah we
don't have enough data I think to really
estimate what that cost would be
but if H the legislature decided to move
it we would take it yeah I didn't get
any objection from the commissioner of
Education no that would not be the
stakeholder I was referring to I see yes
all right well yeah if you could send me
an email or something we'll we'll talk
about this yep separately other
questions no all right thank you very
much so last what do we have here this
morning um we have Department of
energy oh there's one that's off book it
[Laughter]
says let see what page that
is okay all right hold on a moment
commissioner
say it again all right 234
it's
yep page
234 is fun
71 I don't really understand why it's
off book this is a very large amount I
think that comes in and does that it
sure it looks like but yeah we we'll
find
out all right let me get his
okay here we
go are we
ready is clerk
ready are you ready yes okay go ahead
commissioner good morning for the record
uh my name is Jared choin spelled j a r
e d j
Jade
oh
Jared last name chaoin CH hii c o i n
e and I'm the commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of eny energy
excuse me good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
Joshua Elliot uh Elliott is spelled with
two L's and two T's uh I serve as the
Director of the division of policy and
programs with Department
okay all right so let's start with this
fund number
71 sure so with the electric assistance
program which is funded by the systems
benefits charge uh which is found in
statute it's a result of uh
restructuring many years ago um the
electric assistance fund uh provides a
bill discount for lowincome households
on their electric bill um the total cost
to the systems benefits charge I believe
is about um 1 12 Ms per kilowatt hour um
of electricity used um so that every
utility customer pays this charge um and
the uh the program just to let you know
that it does align with li Heap so uh
households making up to 60% of State
median income uh can apply for this
program um happy to answer any questions
you might have about the
details yes well just why don't you
start with why is lately the expenses
been so much higher than the
revenues I'll have Josh speak to
that thank you for the question Mr
chairman so a function of the uh of the
uh electric assistance program and how
it is structured um it is very sensitive
to Electric prices so the actual
individual um per kilowatt hour price of
electricity um so is you see electricity
prices increase um the uh as well as
enrollment um so we know with the last
couple of years um with the increase in
electricity prices there were more
people who were interested in the
program so we had more applicants coming
in the door um so that both drives um
the that drives the expenditure side uh
the fund itself um is a self-balancing
fund so the utilities will deposit
whatever they collect into the fund and
then withdraw whatever they need to be
able to meet the benefits for the uh um
program participants in their respective
utility service territories so it's self
balances so some some months they may
make a deposit to the fund some months
that may be a negative um or may be a
withdrawal from the fund and it sort of
balances out is on a monthly basis so as
we see electricity prices increase we'll
see the revenues um we'll see the
expenditures in increase um as we've
seen um prices come down we've seen the
expenditures decrease
and and roughly 30,000 households were
enrolled in the this previous uh or this
current program
year and representative
Jan um thank you for taking our
questions um
so from 22 to 23 am I to assume by the
expenses that there was a fairly large
increase in rates and then from 23 to 24
electric rates dropped yes that that's
correct so um the war in Ukraine uh
spiked the price of natural gas you know
more than half of the electricity
generated in the region is generated by
natural gas um so obviously you may
remember that the prices of default
Service uh did really Spike um I believe
eversource in that time period was
around 22 cents per kilowatt hour um so
basically it it doubled um and now
prices have come down as the prices of
natural gas have come down um
okay so that that's why you see that
that change thank
you representa I think I missed a number
did you say there were only 30
households in this 30,000 households
30,000 thank
you and uh 60% of income means what of
median income in New Hampshire or yes
State median income
so in the sorry are you you're not done
yeah and there are the other two
programs each seem to have a low and
moderate part to
them how do they
collaborate I'm sorry I which other two
programs are you referring
to um are you referring to fuel
assistance and the weatherization
assistance program
s on not the site committee oh I got
these unattached to each other the
Energy Efficiency
fund
and and the renewable energy fund each
have some some piece that they're
putting into low in moderate income
does it just flow to the
SBC one or um no so there's a couple of
different programs that are designed um
around that same um low moderate income
definition uh the uh the renewable
energy fund uh uses 80% of area median
income which is a slightly different
metric that's usually used at the
federal level uh it's also the um
threshold to qualify for subsidized
housing so for example if you live in a
public housing authority or something or
similar properties um on the uh Energy
Efficiency fund uh that is also aligned
with 60% of State median income those
programs are uh managed by the utilities
through the New Hampshire saves program
um and they also work collaboratively
with the Community Action agencies um
who also do um the intake work for this
program as well so there is there is
overlap and efficiencies in terms of f
coming in the door and being a being
able to be eligible for programs with
one application rather than um having to
go through the same process multiple
times and then that administrative cost
that goes along with that as well is it
also related to heating
energy yes indirectly so the electric
assistance program for this particular
dedicated fund um it there the Community
Action agencies share one common
application among across the entire
state for all three programs so if
somebody coming in the door is looking
for assistance they may not necessarily
they may think oh I need help on my
electric bill there's one place they can
sort of check off the box and they can
they can be uh apply with one form for
all three
programs so people could get get
assistance from all three of
them
yes oh and could I just ask area income
that's a source sport spot in lean in
New Hampshire in Grafton County on does
the is the area the county is the area
which means that Lebanon doesn't qualify
for anything
uh that is that is an excellent question
representative because this is something
we've we've been working through with
some of the other uh uh programs in the
agency so area median income uh they
default to the um us uh Housing and
Urban Development so HUD numbers um how
those maps are drawn I I see you've run
into a similar problem in the Upper
Valley it doesn't necessarily make sense
if you're here on the ground um but
there's uh some of them are done there's
entire counties that are in the same one
and there's some where there are
communities that are areas together that
are in a different one you go over the
Town Line and you have a different set
of numbers to use so it's the HUD
definition yes so yes so we we do not
have any Authority time trying to get
them to fix yes that is something
unfortunately we do not have any
authority over neighboring towns can be
in two different yeah
yeah so so I'm concerned with this fund
that in 20 between 2020 and
20122 it looked relatively under control
right and and then 23 and
24 it it was really drained and we had
to add 1.9 million of General funds so
there's something wrong with either how
we're allocating money to go in or
paying too much to go out such that
there's a problem where where we have to
use General funds which we don't want to
do I don't think if if I could add to
that in
2024 uh this was part of a $9
million extra uh appropriation from your
committee
again there was my point is in 2024 or
whatever we we felt like we had a lot of
money right but but for 2025 I don't
think so
so
anyway well again there's the spike in
prices uh in 22 and 23 in the
legislature um you may recall in
September of 20122 I can't remember it's
a special session or was a veto day um
passed legislation to provide this
additional funding because of the
increase in electric costs so um I guess
my so my question is are you predicting
that 2025
2026 things W will have calmed down and
will look like those earlier years and
so we don't have to change anything that
it's sort of automatically going to work
or are we going to worry that this might
go negative and we'll need General funds
it's always hard to say um given that
the the month-to-month variations and
there's a number of factors that are
outside the control of the department
that might see either uptaking the
program or um just the the cost of
default service um however we have seen
a positive trend in the last 6 months
now granted something else could happen
Global State you know Global events Etc
um that could change uh could have an
impact on electricity prices to the
Natural Gas markets um all else being
equal I think we're in a good spot we
may need need um uh I I can't tell you
right here sitting right now that we
will never need additional funds the
other option is to create a wait list
for the program uh which as the
commissioner mentioned that legislation
was intended to avoid um having to
create a weit list for this
program but you have the authority to do
so if the program ran out of
money uh I believe would that be the
would that be us or that
does uh control the design of the
program and uh how the benefits are
distributed the legislature control is
obviously the amount of money that's
collected uh from the through the SBC in
the past there have been weight list um
when we've had I want to say 2005 when
we had really high gas prices then um
but but there also H have been instances
where the legislature has shifted money
from the e portion of the SBC to the
lowincome um assistance portion uh which
was an emergency um legislation one year
so there are ways to avoid um doing a
weit list uh if possible but also using
a weight list been has been done in the
p uh representative
wer I think this might be fracking
dependent if somebody shuts down
fracking it's going to raise the price
of gas way up or they start making
trouble about fracking I think it's very
dependent on that I would
think uh representative w yes um what
I'm wondering about is is there was also
7,1
100,000 uh
dollars given for outside this program
by the legislature to
rescue the your budget and did
that what was that about and is that
going to
reoccur so so that was our concern uh
about the spike in prices in 2022 um and
making sure that we could provide
assistance to households in
need representative J just a quick
question what were the three programs
one's electric one's Heating and what
was the third one oh sorry uh the
weatherization assistance program um so
that's those are three programs the the
latter two are federally funded um 100%
federal funds oh okay so state is
electric only that's correct okay thank
you all right let's move on to the next
dedicated okay so the renewable energy
fund uh the purpose of this fund is to
support a range of renewable energy
initiatives including incentive programs
for both the residential and
nonresidential sectors um and it is
funded by altern alternative compliance
payments through um the renewable
portfolio standard um and I can just
give you some background on the RPS um
our renewable portfolio standard is a
mandate um it's actually really five
mandates um that requires electric
suppliers uh like our utilities
Community power aggregators and
competitive suppliers to purchase uh a
percentage of their power from certain
classes of renewable energy uh they do
so by purchasing renewable energy
certificates also known as Rex um from
the generators of that renewable energy
in order to put guard rails on the costs
electric suppliers are enabled to make
alternative compliance payments at a set
price if that would be less expensive
than buying Rex if they make alternative
compliance payments those payments go
into into the renewable energy fund
which is administered by uh the
department of energy uh the fund is used
for programs that provide uh incentives
for new renewable energy projects and to
fund um renewable energy initiatives as
I stated happy to take any
questions all right um let me I'll
start so this is a fund that's also
growing somewhat out of control right
you your
expenses um are much lower than than the
revenue at least for the last two years
so something weird happened in
2023 well you'll see our commitments
have increased um and we're about to
issue a new budget um for the next
program year but there's been a number
of of uh of factors uh involved here so
the legislature has made some reforms to
this program in in this last legislative
session which the governor signed into
law um and I can have Josh discuss some
of those uh so there's that um the
programs had changes made to it which we
think are uh are good uh and will have a
positive impact um also we had covid and
the new federal programs and of course
we're tasked with administering many of
those as well uh related to energy and
Assistance programs um so there's been
those factors um but uh you know we we
as you can see our commitments um have
increased uh and we'll continue to do
that and I'll let Josh talk a little bit
about where we're
headed sure um so as part of uh Senate
Bill 303 uh which um passed uh both
houses was signed by the governor
earlier this summer uh made a number of
reforms to what uh programs are
considered part of the renewable energy
fund uh as you can imagine the renewable
energy sector is pretty Dynamic um there
are programs that may have worked 5 10
years ago that are completely irrelevant
at this point and no longer um you know
no longer useful in the market um so we
had a couple of changes made um notably
uh the inclusion of a specific mandate
for the agency to set up a uh program um
specifically for municipality school
districts other sort of um political
subdivisions um so there's a specific
carve out um for them um anecdotally I
can say we have um with some federal
funds we set up a municipal solar
program um so for municipalities that
are looking to install solar arrays on
Town owned facilities um with $1.4
million available uh we got 30
applications um so this is a this is an
area where um we've seen certainly
strong demand for the towns um couple of
other benefits and not only just
reducing the energy costs uh
specifically electric costs for the
municipalities um reduced the costs um
putting downward pressure on property
taxes so sort of a a win-win scenario
there all right representative aling
thank you um you've got a whole bunch of
things in here I don't think that one is
is in the list but
on class two monies are
what thank you for the question um so as
the the commissioner referenced there
are five different um mandates within
the renewable portfolio standard uh a
certain percentage of the electricity
that is sold um needs to have a certain
percentage of a particular renewable
techn techology type so it's not just
Renewables in general there are specific
different classes within um so Class 2
is solar so they uh renewable energy
certificates uh generated from the
installation installation of solar
arrays um so the requirement as you see
it's probably uh it's uh
number uh depending on which um form of
the book in front of me has it as number
three the most recent report that we
filed earlier this summer has it as
number two but um where it's the
discussion of the class two monies need
to be allocated um class two refers to
solar so it's the the direction is any
of the alternative compliance payments
that come in for solar at minimum should
be spent on solar um and I can say that
we we exceed that minimum
requirement so that it doesn't give the
percentage in this list but it gives
other percentages
so um yes so it it requires um that the
the statute if you look all the uh the
the full-blown version of our RSA 362 F
colon 10 um mandates that we spend that
uh the any Class 2 monies received or
alternative CLI compliance payments
received from class 2 specifically need
to be spent on Solar
Technologies so it's
open-ended yes so there's a floor
there's no there's not necessarily a
ceiling other than the other constructs
of the statute
yeah this
is and then it funds non-residential
energy projects but that's kind of
open-ended
too and yes so we uh we issue a request
for a proposal every year for uh
competitive Grant process for those um
so we've seen everything from uh
District heating systems using biomass
um to the renovation and retrofit of um
of small scale hydroelectric dams in the
state and sort of everything in
between yeah it's a little difficult to
figure out how much is going where from
this
list and and what where is is
sometimes we could share with the
committee our budgets that we publish
for the programs we we could provide you
with the previous year and um of course
when we issue the next we could provide
that to the
committee are you suggesting that
perhaps there should be separate
dedicated funds for each of the
uses um well obviously there this is
based partly on the the Reggie uh
mandates M and if the mandate is that
you spend so much and you can spend more
then that's going to be kind of
difficult but yeah if you have a budget
that presented for each of those that
for where it is right now that would
give you an
idea so let me ask this practically is
there an upper limit on the amount of
power power that can come from renewable
energy because renewable energy is not
very controllable in the sense that you
know when it's sunny you'll get a lot of
it and when it's not you'll not and so
on so does it make the whole system at
some
point does it make the whole system
unreliable if you had too much of it and
are we and are we nearing that
point well not practical but anyway well
well and and and I'll have joshh help me
out on this one as well but the um you
know we have a regional grid operator
ISO New England um and they are tasked
with um administering the Wholesale
Electric market and um uh operating the
transmission system and also uh making
sure that we have a reliable system in
New England um so uh I I I'm not sure we
would be uh or or this program would
lead to any uh risk uh for reliability
for the region just because there are
other uh controls in place um that I
think would prevent that and Josh I
don't know if we missed anything but
that's and there are there are a variety
of Market mechanisms the iso New England
has in order to incent uh newer
development um and there's a uh we have
folks who specifically their jobs are to
follow those Market developments and
make sure New Hampshire's interest are
represented um during those discussions
who can speak far more eloquently than I
can about it but there's a series of
mechanism sort of in place to ensure
that the lights stay on um no matter
what the weather is outside and the iso
does considerable planning um for
resources entering the
market all right the reason I'm asking
is this this is pushing people in New
Hampshire to install solar and other
similar things right and so um at some
point presumably you could have more so
ER than there's Demand right and so you
wouldn't you'd want to to dial this back
right so but maybe we're not even close
to that right maybe we're just a a
fraction of the I don't believe this
program alone could lead to
that I uh I would agree with that just
based on um there's no mandates in this
this is if somebody wants to do have
these whatever variety of systems
installed in their homes um it's
entirely up to the the individual
homeowner or the business if want to
Avail themselves of these
programs
okay yeah that's not really relevant but
anyway go ahead representative alling
yeah there are uh two things one there
are places that in in our system because
the electric lines for some reason the
utilities cannot create uh the um a
sufficient so that that people on those
electric lines would be able to install
solar um that's one break on it and and
then um there's something that has been
coming up lately that that I think
started in
uh in Sea Coast
with with um
UNH on and came to Lebanon this last
last year uh which take uses the energy
generated from the methane dissolving in
landfills which is also a reliable quite
reliable source um but the Technologies
are as you know are uh
evolving uh rapidly on the on the
renewable energy side and is there any
um latitude
within the Reggie mandates that allows
for that that extension of different
methodologies to create uh
security uh through improved battery use
and
uh
on methane use and such
Josh could probably speak to the to the
statute better than I but the
legislature can make changes to the RPS
um and if there are changes that you'd
like to make to these various classes um
that is something that that you could
propose tell me about the commitments
column here so it says expenses 2024
expenses 2.8 million commitments
5.4 what does that mean sorry that's a
financial
than that's an incumbrance in our
system so did they really in 2024
spend uh what would it be
8.2
million I think that's for next year
that for the record Rdio r auu t IO I'm
the chief of operations for Department
of energy so commitments are all the
grants and contracts that we have inum
in the system so those are not spent out
yet but they're committed to be spent
for those that um were awarded the um
competitive competitively bid uh grants
and the uh so the really the only
expenses that went out of that account
is the 2.8 million and the 5 million 5.3
million will be spent at some time um
just depending on when the the grantees
have done what they were supposed to do
in order to receive the payment okay but
in 2023 you made 3 million in
commitments but in 2024 you spent less
than 3 million so the commitments aren't
necessarily created in that fiscal year
it could be commitments say um given a
grant for five years it could have been
a commitment that rolled over from a
previous year so we'd have to actually
look look at each individual commitment
to see what that entails if it's from
past years or if it's from the current
year but um you're correct so we enter
into we enter into grants and then
depending on how fast or what what the
requirements of the grants is depends on
how quickly we pay them out because they
have to do they have to do certain
things before they can receive payment
so it could it could lapse over to
different years um just like ones that
we enter into this year we may not we
may pay out a portion of them we may not
pay out till the next year and so if we
made no payments towards these
commitments that 5.3 would roll over
into FY um fiscal year 25 which a lot so
that that's basically what that means is
at the end of the year what are your GR
and what are the commitments for all the
grants and stuff you have and that's the
5.3 so if if there was no more revenue
from now on and there were no more new
grants from now on the ending balance in
this fund When the Smoke Clears years
from now would be $15 million correct
yes sir okay thank
you all right Senator gray if if you
look at this differently on these charts
okay the commitments from one year
okay like if it's a commitment listed in
23 okay you actually pay it in
24 so if you were trying to figure out
what your expenses for 24 is you got to
subtract the 23 commitments and add the
commitments at the end of 24 to know
exactly what you did and that's why this
thing gets so confusing and that's why
we've we've done what we've done so that
you know what the balances are correct
there were some agencies in these
reports that were doing exactly what
Senator Grace said so they were changing
their expense number and other agencies
were not so we stipulated everybody's
got to do it the same way it's not
double counted it's just off to the
right so you can see and have a sense of
what's coming up but it is not specific
to a fiscal year so they may have
multi-year grants a lot of agencies will
spend it the next year and then they'll
do a new one and they'll spend that the
next year so some of them are shortterm
so you have a better sense these guys
have a lot of
multi-year it0 to 90 days really depends
ons of yeah and I can give you an
example you know during covid Supply
chains were disrupted so projects that
we had awarded funding to um you know
either just prior to the pandemic or
during 2020 and 2021 um number of those
contracts we've had to um amend and
extend several times so those projects
because they hadn't met Milestones but
not this wasn't their fault it was just
supply chain issues materials labor
things like that um so you know those
projects will be paid for in full upon
completion but that's going to take some
time representative thank you
uh
the are when you make these commitments
have you all they already got the
permits or is that part of the problem
them and uh do some of those just fall
out because they can't get the
permits there's um usually permitting is
one of the steps um for solar in
particular there's usually an
interconnection question um for you know
existing hydroelectric dams that are
being refitted you you know the
interconnection point or the place they
plug into the grid for a lack of a
better way of putting it um is usually
already there but there's a variety of
other things that um we have as sort of
goal uh Milestones that they need to
meet in order to get payments out and
usually permitting is usually one of the
ones that's up front so we know up front
okay is this is this project going to
happen because you don't want to have
them the give them a bunch of money and
the permitting falls through and then
you're the state's out out of money so
we the permitting is loaded up front one
of the first things that they're
required to
do okay all right any other questions
Senator rosenell thank you and I'm sorry
I miss the beginning of this so if it's
already been asked just tell me to shut
up um I'm looking at this large ending
balance I mean the
balances have been growing in the
renewable energy
fund why are we
not um spending more money out of that
fund are we turning people away are we
cutting programs off or we just not
advertising them correctly so that more
of this money gets spent for the purpose
we've dedicated it
to sure thank you for the question
Senator and the last thing I would ever
tell you would be to shut
up
well um at any rate um no that's that's
a that's a good question right because
that number does jump out on the on the
balance sheet and we've sort of been
discussing this as as um this
conversation has been uh continuing But
to answer it sort of directly headon
it's a variety of factors um so if you
look at the the revenue sides um you can
see that the the revenues have sort of
ranged for this fund down as low as 2.2
in the last couple of years all the way
to uh 8.5 last year so there's a variety
of circumstances that go into that are
outside the state control for how the
revenues come in the revenues are
derived from alternative compliance
payments which are payments made by the
electric distribution utilities
Community power associations and
competitive suppliers anyone who sells
electricity is required under the state
law um to have a certain portion of
their electricity generated from certain
types of renewable resources if for
whatever reason they cannot uh acquire
enough renewable energy certificates to
cover whatever they've sold uh they make
what is called an alternative compliance
payment
those payments um are then deposited
into the fund the renewable energy
certificate Market is a regional market
so there could be a policy change that
is made in Massachusetts that's made in
Connecticut Rhode Island Maine or
Vermont that then impacts what happens
here in New Hampshire and if the price
is for a a comparable renewable energy
certificate is higher in Massachusetts
or if it's lower in Maine the the market
will decide where the best place is the
utilities will decide strategically
where to put any of the renewable energy
certificates that they've purchased in
order to minimize their own cost excuse
me their own costs which are then passed
on to the rate payers so there's a
variety and we don't necessarily know
until the payments come in what that
number is going to be so part of your
question about the programs that's sort
of part of the the the reason um that we
just don't spend every dollar that we
get every year because we don't want to
be opening and closing programs
constantly we don't want to you know
throttle up the money and have say $10
million out on the street for a variety
of programs and then have to immediately
ratchet that back down to a million
dollars the next year so they having
that a bit of stability and being in
within the program so the either the um
individuals or the um or the
organizations or the businesses usually
these programs um when they're coming in
to apply for money are not just uh
they're they're usually applications
that take and planning that takes a
couple of years um to to get to fruition
before they're ready to go so have
having a constant and steady level of
funding um is very important because you
don't want to have that sort of that
whipsaw effect going back and
forth that being said um with two years
of of decent revenues here um we are um
we will have a budget memo as mentioned
earlier to the committee that'll be
coming either out later this week or
early next week um where you'll see an
increase in the amount of funding uh
coupled on with that um Senate Bill 303
which um passed the legislature this
year was signed into law um made a
couple of reforms
through renewable energy fund programs
as you can imagine uh the renewable
energy sector is a particularly Dynamic
one so a program that would have worked
five years ago or 10 years ago is not
necessarily as relevant as it is today
um so we had some uh there were
limitations on where we were sending
money and it was sort of we did some
stakeholder input um about a couple of
programs that were generally not
functioning the way they should and
they're not actually doing what they're
supposed to be designed to do um we're
able to make those reform again with the
with the help of your colleagues um to
make those reforms I'm including uh
adding a specific Municipal uh program
out of the renewable energy fund um
we've heard from a lot of municipalities
um actually a perfect example is the
municipal solar program that we
currently have um funded with federal
dollars um we had 1.4 million available
we got 30 applications um from
municipalities looking to install solar
um so we've seen there's sort of this
strong demand for um uh local political
subdivisions whether it's cities towns
school districts Etc uh looking to do
sort of these more renewable energy
projects but there's not necessarily the
funding that goes along with it then
there sort of the bonus impact of not
only do these communities get to do uh
what they'd like to do in reducing their
own electricity costs um it also uh
reduces upward pressure on property
taxes as well so there's sort of a
there's a win-win there so I apologize
that was a very long-winded answer but
so when you say 30 applications that
doesn't mean anything to me how much
dollar amount are they asking for versus
how much you gave them uh so um I cannot
say at this point because we're still in
the contract negotiation or the grant
negotiation phase with uh with these
communities um so unfortunately I can't
answer that question due to due to state
law but um the uh Municipal program was
a specific set aside in Senate Bill
303 um so that program has not been
developed yet it is just
let me ask the question a different way
you have 1 something million to spend
yes okay 30
applications $40,000 a piece on average
does $440,000 buy you a half of a solar
facility a
quarter you know it depends on a variety
of factors I mean $40,000 doesn't go
particularly far if you're you know if
you're a a town hall or something like
that that does not go very far in terms
of of meting the load um I can say the
program was over
subscribed okay I I'm not I'm not
deliberately trying to be uh Senator but
thank you um as I recall we took this
program out of the
budget
this last year right so we have
less
um maybe less oversight of it but the
the
purposes that it's used to pay for are
onetime they look like
onetime payment somebody puts solar on
their house they can get a rebate
somebody WEA you know does some other
energy saving like I've talked to you
about um heat pump installations those
are
one-time expenses why would it be so bad
to spend down clo not to zero but spend
down more of the money in the
fund given that we're talking about
one-time expenses that an individual a
business or a community ask for it
doesn't have to be
sustainable um I'll answer the second
part first and then I'll have our um our
uh administrative folks talk about the
the first piece of it about the budget
question um so we do have a variety of
those rebate programs um we've been able
to ensure um that with the passage of
303 Senate Bill 303 excuse me that all
those programs remain open so it doesn't
matter that you're trying to shoot for a
narrow window of when the program might
be open in order to get your rebate
right that may the idea is that may make
a decision for somebody on an economic
basis do I do this project or not so
knowing that that money is there is
important in terms of making that
decision because if it's a gamble of
okay the program might be open might be
closed that that there's an economic
decision that's made at that point um
regarding the competitive programs um we
have seen um particular for the low
moderate income solar program uh grant
program so it's a community solar
program um that there are typically are
nonprofits who are usually the ones um
who are coming in who are applying to
get funding to basically build these
arrays and then use them for the benefit
of of low moderate income households um
having more money available as you as
you mentioned makes a difference right
if somebody sees there's $400,000
available someone does the I can't say
risk analysis probably not the right way
of putting it but thinking okay what are
my chances are of of getting this grant
versus if you put more money out on the
street we have seen as you incrementally
put more money out on the street that
you get better response so the last
thing I'd want to do is say okay there's
a whole bunch of money this year and
then maybe it's gone or maybe it's it's
reduced um and then come in you know two
years from now and just say oh sorry no
more we don't have any more money we
can't do this program so it's sort of
this having the cons we've heard from
stakeholders that having consistency in
the amount of funding even if it doesn't
necessarily you know it doesn't dramatic
swings one way or the other it doesn't
help send good Market signals to folks
who are coming in applying for these
funds all right let's move on to the big
fund
here I think
talk this
one so the Energy Efficiency fund was
established in 2008 uh when the New
Hampshire legislature authorized the
state's participation in the regional uh
greenhouse gas initiative um Reggie is a
regional cap and trade program designed
to reduce uh carbon emissions among its
members um it works by establishing a
cap on co2 that generators are allowed
to emit by purchasing Co to allowances
in quarterly auctions um that get baked
into the generator's costs uh the
revenue from those allowances are sent
back to the member states um Reggie has
11 member States including every New
England State um most of these states
have carbon emissions reductions goals
uh New Hampshire does not um the reason
we participate is due in large part
because we're part of the isono England
grid um if we did not participate in
Reggie our ratee payers would still bear
the cost
um however we would lose on the benefit
um so to help thread the needle of this
problem New Hampshire has made the
decision uh to rebate and that was the
legislature to rebate the vast majority
of the funding back to rate payers um to
minimize the costs that we have to pass
on um happy to take any
questions so all of the expenses of this
fund are these rebates or
Not dollar I'm sorry the first dollar of
every allowance goes to uh the Energy
Efficiency funds and administrative
costs um everything above a dollar uh of
each allowance is rebated to um to rate
payers um in the auction that concluded
for the third quarter um just this last
week um roughly I believe 18 million um
was rebated to New Hampshire R
payers 8 out of the 57 or something like
that
Sor uh yeah I just need the numbers
sorry so the auction was
18,6
77,000 and rebate amount was 17,9 52,000
yeah I'm sorry rebate was 177 million
okay so so almost all but there almost
all yeah 650,000 roughly went to the
programs and admin
costs all right by programs there are
some Energy Efficiency things in here
yes low income programs Etc yes now is
that similar to all these programs in
the previous fund or
different similar but but different um
and I can have Josh speak to for
instance the all fuels Energy Efficiency
program sure so um if you're looking um
there's the the series of programs that
are um included as part of that $1 uh
per allowance set aside that the
commissioner referenced um less uh
administrative costs both at the at the
department of energy as well as at Dees
um there are a pair of programs there's
a certain set aside for low moderate
income programs um those are
administered by New Hampshire saves so
those are rolled in with the other
Energy Efficiency programs administered
by New Hampshire saves uh there's a
further $2 million which is set as a set
dollar amount that is made available um
again through New Hampshire saves for
the uh for municipalities doing Energy
Efficiency projects as well uh last but
not least once the basically any of the
the crumbs are left over at the end of
those um uh carats deductions however
you want to refer to them as uh goes
into our uh the Department's uh all
so-called all fuels program um this is
one that we run on a competitive basis
bis um to see basically what you know
what what what are the needs out there
in the market um and where this sort of
funding can can plug those gaps uh
currently the existing program that is
out there um that runs through the end
of the year uh is uh with New Hampshire
saves um which was competitively bid and
awarded to New Hampshire saves um to
provide um Energy Efficiency funding to
those who basically don't qualify for
our um any of the means tested programs
but are still on the lower end of the
income Spectrum so they may not be be
able to meet the full cost match that is
required if they were to go through New
Hampshire saves for example um this
helps defray that cost um to make those
projects um affordable um for those
households uh with the end of that
program um coming up at the end of this
calendar year um we are uh preparing to
do stakeholder sessions um to figure out
what you know what is the need out there
what is the best use of these dollars um
to help form a competitive uh RFP um
that we hope to um undertake sometime
early in the next calendar year all
right other questions from the
committee represent
not oh I'm sorry because this is uh the
regional greenhouse gas initiative um
there are uh emissions testing that they
have staff that will go out and do um so
there's that sort of that the compliance
piece of it uh on the opposite end that
our colleagues at Dees
handle you're welcome sorry I just sort
of clossed over for
that right I'm not seeing any other
hands here all right the last
one so for the site evaluation committee
I'm going to ask uh Andrew Beamer the
SEC administrator uh to come up and
speak to that
fund I think this is his
salary am I right
mostly greetings I am Andrew Beamer b i
m and I'm the administrator of the
SEC go
ahead basically my agency which has now
been uh rolled into the Pu per
legislation last year uh we generate
Revenue by the um uh filing fees for new
facilities upgrades and transfers of
ownership historically that's ebed and
flowed significantly you have things
like the Northern Pass project that
obviously despite not being built filed
seven figures worth of filing
fees uh then you have years such as I
believe last year 2023 we had zero
Revenue in terms of filing fees that is
because nobody tried to build anything
nobody tried to upgrade anything and uh
fortunately nobody filed any complaints
against any utility companies that
required investigation that is another
that was another source of um of revenue
for the
agency um so basically what we're
looking at here is the salary um the
expenses of my agency are basically my
salary plus um other office expenses and
then Money Paid to other agents
who assist me in the um execution of my
responsibility so now that you're part
of the P can can your all of this
activity be part of their budget and and
can we get rid of this
fund that would be a question of whether
or not the regular utility assessment
can support these type of payments I
don't know if uh commissioner has has
any uh comments on that or if that's a
legislative
decision I would imagine you be a
legislative decision so right now these
the actions of this committee are not
funded by the general utility assessment
that's why there was a dedicated fund
set up for it um that would have to be a
legislative decision on whether or not
those could be
used but effectively there's hardly any
Revenue here so it's really the general
fund paying for this right that is
correct and so yeah go ahead
representative Al me yes but if someone
puts in another major pro project there
is going to be both revenue and the need
for the
revenue that's accurate the the the good
thing about the funding mechanism if you
will is that when there's a lot of work
to be done we're also collecting a lot
of filing fees in general the filing fee
for a new generation facility I believe
is uh around $60,000 as a base fee and
then there's um additional
money per megawatt or per uh per mile of
transmission if the case may be and we
um there are incentives um for instance
where the fees are slightly less if
you're trying to build renewable energy
versus if you were trying to build a
coal facility um but in the instance of
that yes we would have the ability to
fund that through two mechanisms really
the first one is the filing fees that
come to us when they file the
application for the permit the second
one is the committee itself has the
ability to charge the applicant extra
money for the hiring of external
Consultants so that money is paid um I
don't actually physically touch the
money what happens in that instances the
SEC will say to the developer whoever
that is we're going to need to hire an
outside attorney to help us with this
case the we take bids we determine the
uh the contractor for that task and then
that person sends their bills to me I
approve them and then I send them
directly to the uh to the applicant so
in the case of the northern past just
since it's a big example we can all
remember there was a gentleman working
as a council for the committee and that
gentleman was being paid directly by
ever source with the approval of um the
invoices by the administrator
uh representative
wer so what did the SEC do on the year
that there was no activity well the the
the filing fees are collected in the
year of the filing so uh last year for
instance I had multiple open dockets one
of them was a long investigation into
the Anum Wind Facility that a lot of you
are probably at least you know
peripherally familiar with there was an
upgrade to a facility at um at C Brook
and there were series of Investigations
and other permitting issues that had
preceded the the fiscal year so the
dockets were um we were still working on
2022 matters in the year 2023 we just
weren't getting new ones thank
you me just to get that clear you're
talking about the actual
year
2023 not not F FY
23 I'm actually I was probably talking
about FY 2023 right because that's
what's reflected here yes he the okay
yeah I was when I said 2023 to be clear
apologies I meant fiscal year 2023 okay
so in fiscal year 24 which is also
finished you were still working on a
number of these
that's accurate and we had one filing
just for the record was a um it was a
transfer of
ownership which is a pretty basic fee in
the old construction of the SEC which we
were still under at that time you had
the option to request review by a
subcommittee which would have been 3600
and the full committee I believe was
something like um uh $12,000 $112,000
somewhere in that range so they request
Ed and were granted the ability to have
that heard by a subcommittee hence the
$3600 revenue in fiscal year
24 represent could I just ask you on one
of the problems that you had and
probably still have is that it is the
directors of different agencies that
represent that staff these committees
rather than you and a bunch of them
don't seem didn't seem to be terribly
interested in showing
up one of the issues was at the
subcommittee level the subcommittee
level would see a high level of rotation
because a lot of them would appoint um
designes and the issue there was that
when the subcommittees were doing the
bulk of the investigating or the bulk of
the adjudicating as in the case of
antrum which took two years you had
multiple
generations of designes literally
retiring from state government uh so
there was there was turnover there um
regarding the actual heads of the
agencies that were on the SEC that was
Transportation Dees cultural resources
Bea the three pu Commissioners and then
two public members they were all to a
person phenomenal and there were certain
times when we would have to have a
hearing on a specific day or within a
specific time frame where we couldn't
get all of them but by and large the um
the ex officio members who were
department heads were excellent or their
designes were excellent because they
would put in somebody who they knew was
better equipped for the task at hand for
instance they gave me a sound engineer
for a docket that had to do with sound
now in the new construction of the SEC
we have five people to establish a
three-person quorum that's the Pu plus
one public member and plus the
commissioner of environmental services
so the Quorum however cannot only be the
Pu that was written into the law so it
would have to be two PE theoretically it
shouldn't be hard to get everybody but
if we were only going to be able to get
three people it couldn't just be the 3
puuc it would have to be two of them
plus a public member or two of them plus
Dees long way of saying I think the um
the changes that we've made in the past
year are going to go a long way towards
um avoiding avoiding those issues in the
future thanks all right so maybe I'll
talk to the person who sponsored the
bill to move you to to pu and see if
they intended to move your funding to
their funding as well right
so out of the general
fund we I'll talk about that okay if I
if I may yes go ahead um regardless of
the you know yes the using general funds
is not is not ideal but if there ever
was a uh a docket like like northern
pass for instance we would need a
mechanism to collect those the the
funding for those you'd still have that
right the you'd still have the fee for
the do for the application but it's
right so um so the changes to the SEC
the the funding mechanism in down years
where there are no applications was not
addressed that is correct yeah I mean
but it it would just not be this
dedicated fund it could go into their
accounts right the
pu's accounts yeah well the only account
that pu has is the general utility
assessment we wouldn't want those the
fees being used to fund General utility
type so the real question is keeping you
you want to keep this fund but possibly
the source of funds not general fund but
this other fund is that what we're
talking about yes sir okay good I can
also I can also tell you I believe it
has not come up operationally thus far
because we're still new into the new the
new um Incarnation but I believe that
when I am working on SEC specific
projects my funding is coming
specifically out of this right here that
we're talking about and when there is no
SEC work or minimal SEC work and the Pu
decides to pull me in as a fungible
resource to help on something that that
is coming out of their funding mechanism
so so they are separate you I think your
your question about asking the bill
sponsor for the original intent would be
a good idea because um
um right I mean this says over the years
642 th000 of general fund was spent on
this right
so okay um so I'll just say before we go
for lunch um this summer I drove 20
hours north of Montreal and toured the
LR
2 uh Power Plant which is what would
have sub one of the plants that would
have sub been for Northern Pass and it
was absolutely fascinating and I think
it's a real shame that that didn't go
through um but it but it was a very
worthwhile trip if anybody is interested
in that kind that thing so all right so
we'll come back at 1:00 are we happy
yeah okay thank
you yes it was a lot of fun I'm hoping
to finish
them um I'd just like all of you to know
that the
color uh part that I put in for resource
and natural res cultural resources so
that you could could figure out what
goes with who on isn't on those sheets
unfortunately I should have made copies
for everybody or did hash mark or yeah
well what I I did do in each case in the
first one
on it says over here yell
612 numbers are a cluster including 9 46
33 77 and administrative unit
5200 which is not even
is this
one so this we have individual handouts
from all of the agencies this is the one
from Department of energy so you have
that you
yeah that came first we had that from
last
week I think it came before
that
e
e e
do you mean by CL
um yellow which you can't see um they're
they're similar is that they are well
those are less
interacting necessarily but they're
forestry oh I see then the orange ones
are Canon mountain and those are
definitely oh I
see all right they start with
okay so let's get started it's one
o'clock wonderful um are you
commissioner Stewart I am commissioner
Sarah Stewart commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources and with me Chris Marino the
chief of
administration okay thank you for coming
Marino
Marino yeah he's the person who
signed
okay all right so should we start with
number
nine it's right in
order Forest Improvement fund
uh yes and just just to clarify we do
have the uh division heads here as well
if there are any specific questions
relative to the funds that you wish to
have clarified by them okay so so this
one looks almost defunct right it's got
$146,000 and two years ago you spent
some money or something like that 140 I
see
$142,000 yeah the current balance that's
correct the activity has been uh minimal
in this in this account U as of late
um but it is a continue it does continue
to be used you'll notice uh between the
years 20 and
2022 there were some substantial amounts
that were encumbered
um but it it looks like this is done on
a periodic basis so as the fund builds
the the funds are used and then there
may be periods start with a description
and then sure yeah do you do you want
directors to do it or do you want I'm
sure actually yeah that would be that
would be fine if if you ask the chair he
may let you sit I think that would be
helpful multiple people yeah I mean if
the others want to sit over there I
think that would be helpful just because
yeah that if the directors could grab a
microphone that way they can jump in
because they're more intimately aware of
the impacts of these funds thank you
yeah good suggestion
plenty of chairs on this
side turn that
right all right director Hackley do you
want to just briefly
explain the account that uh we're
opening with thank you just for the new
people we can't have too many mics on at
the same
time
on okay all set all right my name is
Patrick Hackley I'm the director for the
division of forest and lands so this
Forest Improvement fund falls under our
um division oversight um while it
doesn't look like there's been a lot of
activity in this fund it is an important
fund for us to maintain to have
Reserve funding for Acquisitions and
dispositions um we're always looking
strategically at our landbase to see
what we want to see if we can acquire a
property that's adjacent to an existing
State
Reservation or in the case of perhaps
you're aware of Allen State Forest it
was a 30 acre parcel that recently was
approved by governor and Council the
proceeds from that sale which is very
close to being
transacted will go into the forest
Improvement fund that's where these
funds will live and we're actually
working with um a conservation group and
the town of Effingham to acquire an 88
acre parcel that's adjacent to our Heath
Pond bog Forest uh so having this fund
gives us that flexibility to park funds
and then to use them for um Acquisitions
as well as dispositions because
sometimes an appraisal is needed which
can usually be
$5,000 per report um surveys are
sometimes needed although we do have a
survey staff a survey um crew on staff
um it's just it's well like uh uh
director Marino said it doesn't have
doesn't appear to have a lot of activity
we are planning to have a lot more
activity on it and case in point was the
Allen State Forest sale I just mentioned
so what do what do you mean by State
Reservation uh basically lands that the
state owns we our our division is
charged with managing all the state
reservations under the jurisdiction of
dncr um so that includes Parks as well
about 270 280,000 Acres across the
state so what is it other than Parks is
it the the land under this building or
no no so other state agencies like do
um fish and game yeah fishing game has
over 60,000 Acres we actually uh have a
partnership with fishing game to manage
their Wildlife Management areas so we
I'm just referring to when I say State
reservations those are the um properties
that are under our management under this
Department's
management right so my question was what
what is it that's not a
park oh State Forest yeah so if there's
no developed recreational facilities on
the property then it we typically
categorize that as a state forest which
means it's strictly undeveloped forested
land and that's what you sold recently
as some of that correct I see gotcha and
how much do you expect that sale to go
for I think uh this price tag is about
132,000 okay so you're looking to buy
something right we're working with a
conservation fund that's providing
really staff resources in kind to help
us transact a deal with um uh private
land owners in Effingham and uh we're
using those funds as match to a federal
uh program that's available to us other
questions uh Senator roswan thank
you um am I correct that we've been
spending some arpa funds to
acquire land and so we don't have we
haven't had to
spend these dedicated
funds um not that I don't think as far
as dncr no goes yeah not through
dncr May maybe yeah but not we haven't
used any arpa funds for land
acquisition do invol me thank you so any
Forest that has recreational trails in
it is considered a park no which will
get confused with no ma'am I typ
typically so we have two different
basically two different types of zoning
in our state reservations Recreation and
Forestry if it's Recreation it would be
something akin to like Bear Brook State
Park where we have actually developed
campgrounds and cabins infrastructure
Trails we don't technically consider
infrastructure it's we do have Trails
through some of our state forests
um but those areas can still be zoned
forestry so this would be places where
there's significant
recreational uh building in
particular where would call it a park
yeah or or recreational zoning
recreational zoning but it's not a
recreational Forest even though it's
mostly trees technically all of our
forests are recreational but we have we
have formal zoning based on
the the amount of development in that on
that reservation yeah the trails Bureau
is under the state parks there Trails as
you know on private land Municipal um
nonprofit forest and lands Parks um so a
lot of our state forest also have trails
that are connected um through other ways
as
well but they're they're they're under
you because you're the ones that
purchased them it's some
point the property under that we manag
through
dncr was at some point purchased or
acquired uh for either forestry or
Recreation when you sell um Timber does
it go into this fund no sir we're going
to be talking about that Fund in a
little bit
okay
question okay there was I'm sorry um you
had something in there about also the
possibility of renting
out some of these there was something
about rentals yeah that's in the
language of the statute but um in my
short tenure here as the Director I
don't see that as a uh a notable source
of income I don't even know what it
would be to rent out equipment forestry
equipment of some kind but it's mostly
forestry land forest land yeah
yeah so we can take that out it don't
only appeared in one place I
think and what are the other sources do
you know from fy20 and 21 when you got
the only money you've had in five
years only significant money 100,000
each
yeah um so that was actually just prior
to my arrival um it was in the in the
account that was relative to a property
that The Nature Conservancy had Acquired
and intended to convey it to the state
we were going to reimburse The Nature
Conservancy uh and and and own that
property acquire
it however I believe this is related to
Forest Legacy which is a federal program
that provides funding for purchasing
conservation lands um
course Legacy allows the landowner to
dictate whether they'll allow ATVs or
snow bills
Etc and does any if anyone remembers
this I'm looking over at you
commissioner if uh if we remember but I
believe the government council did not
um approve of us acquiring it because we
could not control the recreational
activities they wanted to make sure
there was going to be available for
ATV uh use so that money stayed in our
account we did not disperse it or
acquire that
parcel thank you all right now we got
Timber
sales so 356 Timber sales another state
lands this is where the revenue from
Timber sales related to our partners at
fishing gain gets dep
positive and the revenue that's
generated from these sales supports we
have two Foresters on staff and their
salary benefits are basically entirely
covered by the revenue generated by
Timber sales from managing the Wildlife
Management areas so it's a it's a
symbiotic relationship we conduct their
management according to wildlife habitat
principles they cover the cost of our
Foresters to implement those
plans we also do uh forry work for other
agencies but it's on a rare occasion um
I think there's been some proposals with
the Department of Transportation
actually owns quite a bit of land and
some of it's has manageable Forest on it
but we haven't uh done one of those
projects in several
years now why are you showing negative
Revenue in
2023 is that an
expense right 2023 I I think is just
when the the B we we had a revenue but I
don't think we typically run a deficit
yeah if I if I may speak to that that
was actually an accounting practice that
was that was occurring at the time so
what happened was the expenses were
being combined with the revenue and
ultimately in this case what that means
is there was there was more Revenue than
there was expense we changed that
practice we we we we want to change that
practice so that the expenses show up on
their own line and the revenue shows up
in a separate line so
this is an accounting practice that's
going on that combines the two so it it
does make it seem a little bit unclear
um I think we've done that I don't think
we've incurred any expenses in the last
couple of years um but that that was
ultimately that was the the result of an
accounting practice that was that made
it very unclear we just heard there are
two employees getting their salaries
from this right so
there there should be regular
expenses yes so the the the employees
are paid through the source of funds out
of this
account and the expenses occur in the
account but the expenses in this case
for these years again are showing up
combined against the revenue so we we
need to clarify that
yeah could you redo this this page yes
yes I can I can clarify that right thank
you other questions about this
okay yeah I represent have a question
here which is do we want to continue
with forestry which would take us into
um
46377 and an administrative unit at the
very end of the pages yeah and then we
could release this
fell do some
[Laughter]
work that's a good idea all right so I'm
the only one that has the colored
version of this unfortunately but I did
put at the beginning of each colored
section that these are a yellow cluster
in this case um and refer to
6129 46
377 and a Au 5200 which is off book
somehow so where are we going now 36 um
we're going to 46 46
okay which is on the next
page or not the next page of this thing
so right
right whatever you do in this department
requires going back and forth on the
pages all right it's page page seven of
of their uh report
okay very good all right let's
continue sure so I'll just jump in and
let you know that 355 it's our
accounting unit um management and
protection fund this is probably one of
our most important funds um as you can
see it generates a fair amount of
Revenue and uh we basically use this to
uh compensate our entire Forest
management Bureau
staff um with the exception of the
administrator who's generally funded but
all the other
staff I off the top of my head I think
we have um at least 12
12 Foresters on staff um might be off by
one or two um we've had a r one
retirement we just hired a new Forester
but the the and this this also
funds um equipment um it it also funds
uh not entirely but a portion of the
natural heritage Bureau
staff it really funds all of our bureaus
we have seven bureaus in our division
and and this 355 is our kind of our our
pivot account we pull funds from this
account obviously legitimately according
to the statute to fund much of our staff
as you may know from from doing the the
pre-work on this hearing our division is
only about 30% funded with General
funds the rest of it comes from other
income which of which this is a major
source then we have federal
funds um that's basically the three
buckets of money are federal funds other
income and general funds so um and cons
plate which is you know technically
taxpayer money but it's in a different
category so um that's the nature of this
um when we do a Timber Harvest on State
Reservation land again whether it's Park
or Forest land the proceeds from those
sales go into the fund and then on an
annual basis are then uh used to
compensate our staff and to
supply um funding for the other bureaus
as
mentioned but why aren't Timber sales
from the in the previous
F the timber sales from the previous
account we just talked about 356 yeah we
keep that separate uh just to keep track
of um those those because those are from
fishing game Parks correct and other
state agencies like fishing like like I
mentioned I see this is from your own
correct I see okay yep yep thank
you so essentially it's it's our our
it's really our our pivotal account and
it's been uh a very well-maintained and
well managed um account we feel like
it's the bread and butter we do have
some concerns over
time um with warming Winters and wetter
Summers our Timber sales program uh
we've been doing very well for the last
few years but this past year was we're
well below our 10e average in Timber
harvesting so that that is of some
concern for us because you know uh Force
management is affected by weather and
ground conditions so um we have to be
mindful of that in in regards to the the
source of the major source of funding
into this
account right but this has a
considerable balance right I mean it's
close to two years worth of
expenses so so you know if if a year is
is even 25% up or down it it's not going
to be
you can easily cover it here we we do
have a a healthy balance but that's by
Design um given given what I just
mentioned in regards to bad weather
Seasons um markets are such that we
don't always get a consistent price for
our Timber um that fluctuates with the
economy um we're seeing softer prices in
White Pine logs and in red oak logs so
markets weather and then just the budget
cycle as we all know we're looking at a
much tighter General funding uh
imperative by um the state budget office
so we feel like we we need to have that
balance to be assured we can keep our
forestry staff employed to do the
mission that we're required to
do what was the other funds of 181,000
in
2020 that I can't speak to um I'm sorry
Mr chairman could you point specifically
he's looking at 20 the 2020 line on the
chart Chris um
18155 3 that year other sources oh other
sources yeah typically what that
represents is a balance that has been
carried forward from a prior
year uh of accumulated uh funding that
is designated for something that is held
in
incumbrance so in other words all of the
normal sources Timber sales State
Nursery seat sales leases administrative
finds all of that is accumulated in the
revenue column other sources typically
is a figure that
represents some kind of a of an
adjustment to the account that is not
specific to those primary sources in
this case it's a matter of management of
balances for for encumbered activity
okay uh representative Aly can you
remind me when you were
created division of
theis National okay division of and land
or the department um uh
2017 when Governor made his first um
yeah address there was considerable
confusion yeah as that happened and for
years after yeah we still are reminding
people who we
are other
questions all right um any more forest
related
ones yes one one not two actually
they're both at the end
um now I've got to go back and forth
between
sheets on 377 and I
think uh Au 5200 is right after it okay
so the last two in our on our
spreadsheet hopefully the last two in
here
yeah 133 and 13 no no no 33 we're going
off of their handout oh all right I'm
trying to get on oh that one 33 no 33 we
we'd already
done Forest protection Personnel
training fund
no that's this one
it's on page 33 of this little
hand and if you want the book it's page
159 that's can Canon Mountain ski
account you're on page five oh oh page
33 yeah no that makes more sense because
it's the last ones in
here
okay yeah okay
questioning
fund yes tell us what what what is this
about and where all of our rers we have
11 rers on staff all of them are
required to be train Wildfire
suppression infection activities and we
do receive uh support from the US for
service but U the training fund allows
us to buy equipment important equipment
for them Ro those yellow uh shirts that
you see them wearing um uh the tools
that they need um and and these costs
are significant when we mobilize a crew
to send out WEA for instance we've sent
about four different Crews combination
of New Hampshire Main and Southern New
England personel to fight fires out
west while they're out there they're
getting critical Wildfire trans through
that they to be prepared when they come
back here to New Hampshire um it's it's
proven to be a very good program for for
us um all of our expenses when we
mobilize crews are reimbursed by the
forest
service um so this fund helps uh cover
the additional cost to to suit up and
equip our our
Personnel so it's kind of a critical
part kind of a mission critical source
of funding that we need if we're going
to have a viable Forest protection
staff except that you're $40,000 in the
hole right now
yeah um well this is a snapshot in time
so I don't see it as a I we we are
typically reimbursed when we have
deficits from the for service so I'm not
sure if
that that really that will probably go
away once we get full reimbursement
because we're still in a wildfire season
actually that's correct it's it's
federally funded this just a matter of
timing of the reimbursement that draws
from the feder program so we are they
are awarded
authorized significant amount of money
um and it is a reimbursement basis we
incur the expenses we then submit the
for reimbursement and the draws occur uh
just so happens at this CA in this case
at the end of fiscal year 24 we had not
received the draw for reimbursement in a
timely fashion and so it appears as
though the account is maintaining a
deficit but that's really just an
accounting deficit the uh the funds will
will be drawn and reimbursed but but it
says here that you're getting money from
fines right as part of it yeah so what
does that mean by what do you mean by
reimbursement well the program itself is
considered reimbursement meaning we
incur the costs and then seek
reimbursement from the source of funding
that that's mentioned further down
rather than in master Cooperative yeah
well what's this fines part
oh fines is if someone comes cut when
there Harting violation
or try not to speak forry lingo here but
basically when there's an infraction of
a forry law in the state we have a fine
structure based on our rules and when we
issue fines that Revenue comes into um
is allowed to be a funding source for
this particular training fund
typically though Chris I think it comes
in 355 and then it can be transferred
over to the training pond so that might
be part of that that Matrix that we're
talking
about so that's a minor I'm sorry that's
a minor part of this it is essentially
yes it's a small amount yes but it's
allowed go more
than maybe five to 10,000 in a given
year total
small fraction of the total cost of
having a training
program okay question yes representative
W do you assess fines for Timber
harvesting on private
lands sort of fine would they be what
sort of penalty so we have basal area uh
laws basil area is basically
the e
representative
Jan yes as I look at this um you know 20
2021 through
2024 beginning balance column uh in
general there's a a degradation of that
beginning balance is that also so
because of an
accounting calculation that that hasn't
given us the correct beginning balance
or or why or why is that dropping yeah
so so many times that balance it's it's
really driven by the relationship
between when the expenses are incurred
and when they draw but also you may have
years where you incurred more expenses
or less expenses so that number can go
up and down depending on how much is
expended from year to year
yeah um but as as that makes sense but
just in general it looks like it's
trending downward is there some reason
for that or again is that just a quirk
or because in 2021 it was 136,000 I can
see in
2022 it was less than half and then 2023
it kind of rebounded but in general it's
looks like it's weakening
well like it it does appear that the the
trending of expenses is going up uh year
to year um which would ultimately drive
down that beginning balance that makes
sense but ultimately that beginning
balance will never we can't draw more
than what is available from the award so
yes but I would say and Patrick director
Hackley could probably speak to this
more clearly but it looks like there's a
a lot more activity occurring in the
last few years uh from the source of
this fund than has occurred previously
yes Senator Rosen thank you I'm trying
to waigh through this
RSA language and it seems
like not all of the fines go into the
forest protection Personnel training
fund
maybe can't even tell if it's 80% or if
it's
20% but where does the balance
go it would go into the um
3505 the forest management protection
fund
yeah and the last one oh one more
representative
voling are the people who you send out
west volunteers
they are they they staff um but we also
have U private individuals who are
trained that agree to go out they do get
compensated by the forest service yeah
the staff doesn't have to go out they
they don't they're strongly recommended
for training purposes but um some
Rangers opt out yeah yeah sounds like a
pretty horrific job it's it's rugged
work for sure
right the last one is Fox Forest trust
FS um so this is a property that was
donated to us from Carolyn
Fox um and she did leave a a an
endowment and we do use this to fund a
we have a a Forester there that's uh
basically our um manager of that
property and the buildings that that
came with the property we did we did
build an educ a very small Educational
Center on on site
um and we draw from that periodically to
pay for insurance operating costs and a
portion of the salary for the Forester
goes um comes from these funds to
maintain that staff
person it is a research and
demonstration station we have workshops
out there
um it's been a a great location for
doing civil cultural showings to to uh
help the public and other
Foresters understand how to manage a
forest for for various purposes um
whether it's hardwood civil culture
softwood Civic culture Forest Health our
forest Health uh staff also is housed
there at the at the Fox Forest
location um and so it's a really
important Southern Facility for our
division and and the uh endowment fund
helps us maintain the property um and
and as I mentioned the Forester that
manages the that
site very good this is in the town of
Hillsboro correct representative
wer gosh I should know that off the top
of my head but it's probably um it's got
to be at least 1,200 to 1500 Acres I'm
putting a thumb in the air on that
one sure any other forestry
questions see none thank you very much
thank you all right so now what do we do
go back to the beginning back to the
beginning
okay back to page that's number
13 uh 12
13 all right fund
13 um North Region headquarters is that
the one you're referring
to because that would fall under my
teritory yes yes glad to skipped it yeah
it's on page four yeah 7871 accounting
unit so the North Region headquarters is
under our divisional jurisdiction and
under our department it's a dncr
facility and our division manages it um
we house our forestry staff there for
the North Region they're responsible for
managing our largest State Forest the
40,000 acre Nash stream
Forest um we also um provide space to
our colleagues in in Parks and
Recreation so Bureau of trails has a
couple of staff there as well um we then
also lease space at a fairly friendly
rate to uh our our partners in education
Outreach UNH Cooperative Extension has
an office there and then our colleagues
at the fishing game uh Department also
have office space there so it's really a
great um nucleus of state agencies
resource-based agencies that uh occupy
the North Region headquarters in
Lancaster um we do receive proceeds from
the timber taxes that are collected from
the unorganized
townships and each year we present a
budget as a matter of fact we're
preparing to present a budget now for
the 2025 fiscal year to coas County and
uh their Commissioners review our budget
and then allocate a portion of the
Timber taxes that are collected from the
unorganized townships to help fund this
North Region
headquarters all right so it looks like
you you very closely keep the revenue
and expenses uh
aligned yeah this one's pretty tight
um and uh we we've we've been able to
recently Rec we had some questions about
the value that we we provide the the um
the value proposition to the county uh
but we've recently solidified that
support we receive roughly $668,000 a
year from Coos County to supplement the
uh the
additional uh Revenue that we need to
keep the the headquarters
running and and it has become quite the
community center in terms of meetings
meeting space um there's some fine
looking stuffed animals in there um but
it is a well-used uh facility in
Lancaster for many state agencies and
the public so you're saying they pay
above the timber tax that they collect
not above they pay a portion of uh of
the Timber tax
collected uh from the or unorganized
townships and that's been a ongoing
statutory uh you know based in statute
for
decades and it's just a negotiation as
to what fraction of that tax they give
you yes yeah it's it's uh it's
negotiated between um the Commissioners
and and me and our our division I
see representative
Aly thank you Grafton county has one
town in this uh one town non
toown um it actually had a resident for
a while
um but on who
who pays when there is a
fire in or or other violation in right
in that area right for a wildfire um so
if it's in the unorganized Township we
do we we do look to uh the county to
cover that but that's I think that's
also tied into our the the allocation if
you will that we receive from the
commission I'm not totally clear on the
mechanics of that
but um I think we look to the county if
it occurs in an unorganized Township
where there are no year round
residents other
question repr on yeah there are
besides um summer visitors okay well
including the summer visitors there are
a fair number as I understand it of
mansions hidden in the backlands of Coos
mhm that belong to people mostly from
New York
City who only G there once a year turns
your stomach doesn't it
no um we actually yes yeah so if if one
of those Mansions happens to burn down
to the ground is that the problem of the
county
or so we have actually in the past
assisted
um the county in in patrolling these
back roads that have
significant uh second homes on
lakes and uh reported those back to the
um the tax administrator for the county
to let them know that they have a
significant structure in the back
country at at this point the sheriff's
office is doing that now but they're
spending time on those back roads to
quantify so there those taxes should be
reflected in um
uh the property
assessment when they know that there's a
property out there and that that did
happen a lot after um covid um people
were beefing up their camps to to to
live more frequently up there or just
buying leases and building significant
structures but I I do know what you mean
that trend has yeah occurred yeah even
before that they I got my information
from the person that uh furnished the
interior of a number of those
places all right the next Forest one I
see is number 376 on page
32 is that yours also
37 um marac River Basin oh yeah all
right I missed didn't I
Forest management and silvicultural
operations on federal lands it's a
license with the Army Core of Engineers
oh yes yeah I can explain that one so in
addition page 32 yes um yep uh
accounting unit
5019 Forest management civil cultural
operations on federal lands so very
similar to our relationship with New
Hampshire fishing game department we
also manage about 13,000 acres for the
US Army Corps of
Engineers so as many of you know um when
the federal land dams up land they they
acquire lands around it um flood plane
lands if you will and this agency
contracts with us well we have a anou or
an MOA to provide Force Management
Services on their property and that
supports a Forester that is on our staff
so there are no General funds here we
rely this fund to support um I think
just one
Forester um and but it also um provides
funding for mowing uh we we contract
with a an outside consultant to mow um
the areas around the dam so basically
are the land manager for the US Army
Corps of
Engineers representative m
it's not just um the miramac River Basin
it's also some it's prominy the marac
River Basin um yeah there it says right
there it says 11,700 my understanding is
it's closer to 13 so they maybe um I
don't know if that includes the
Blackwater area the Blackwater Dam Area
and that's kind of in that hopkington
um kukuk area but we we have done Forest
operations on other
um Army Corps properties and that may be
the balance of the 13,000 Acres I'm
thinking
of yeah that's what it does okay um any
questions on this
one all right good
um so any other Forest I didn't see any
but
do you do mining
much we're hoping you Wen going to bring
that
[Laughter]
up ridiculously
it's we we can speak to it when I when I
started in this position I thought oh
wow mining we might be able to find a
fortune that's not that's not happening
no no it's more of a a chore than a
benefit it's one of those things we were
as an agency saddled with here it's like
here you take the mining um activity so
director Marino and I had page 15 yeah
let's go to the page and um we'll talk
about it a little bit so we lease out
State Reservation land for mining
permits um but we also are obligated
under the statute to uh monitor mining
operations on private land um so it
falls to us and um the permit fees over
time have accumulated to this amount
that you see in the in the table
um it's it's a fairly lengthy
RSA um but our obligations are to
monitor to
inspect um and to ensure that there's a
mining plan associated with these
mines
um this is handled by Our Land
Management Bureau
staff um the funny you see there has has
probably been there for quite some time
a number of years we have not tapped
into it to ad ad Minister this act
basically what the fund what the statute
says is um these funds may be used to
administer the ACT which is very
ambiguous and um doesn't really help us
in terms of what what we can use the
money for so either we we would seek
legislative or either through rules or
legislative action of some kind seek to
be able to tap those funds for the
administration of the monitoring and in
case of
disputes we sometimes need to incur
costs um for instance we had an AB
budding land owner who was upset with
the noise being made by the mining
operation um we started to work with our
doj attorney we were going to conduct a
deciel study of the mining activity the
quote we got from the contractor was
about $5,000 which was half of what our
balance is in this fund um but we
weren't really able to tap it because
the language in this RSA isn't really
explicit is that a fair characterization
director
Marino yes I would say that was would
probably be a good interpretation uh we
we did just discussed it recently um
because of the vaguery of the chapter
and it does say administration of the
chapter um we're I'm inclined to think
that this is an exercise that would fall
within the authority of this chapter so
I'm inclined to to say yes go ahead with
that but I'm glad we're having an
opportunity to met to talk about this
now yeah um just in case there's any
opportunity to to see clarification on
that representative
wer this is mostly dirt and gravel right
or u a hobby mineral collection um
quartz and then there's barrel and
there's some other precious gems that
that these miners are after but uh it
actually it's not some of it's um uh
surface uh uh Granite quaries where the
slabs left over from from actual
drilling are now being sold because they
have value yeah we have one like that in
Fitz William I believe thank you do you
have a full-time employee dealing with
mines or no not she does not deal with
it's really this extra work and to be
honest the the state geologist I think
is housed at
Dees yes and so yeah and so this is in
my opinion something worth considering
where does this belong
um because it really is sort of an
afterthought with our staff because it's
not a primary function but uh we do get
calls or complaints or or um inquiries
about this
responsibility I see so you would like
to have the state geologist or you'd
like to get rid of this
fund I think the state geologist would
be better suited to oversee this type of
work right but should the state
geologist work for Department of Natural
Resources or Dees right do you I think
that's a conversation I'm willing to
have with Dees I don't know specifically
what other roles and responsibilities
the geologist has okay that that would
benefit either uh agency I mean we all
all agencies try our best to look beyond
the The Branding of the agency so we're
all on the same page um but this is one
that has um bubbled up in conversations
as let's let's look at this a little
closer and talk to Dees and see if it
has a better home over there or vice
versa all
right now um are the fees involved here
adequate to the the work that they the
minds cause or
not well
um that's a good question we I'm
beginning to think no given the current
stat in we have now we recently moved
our
Communications section out of Land
Management Bureau and we created our own
Communications Bureau so that's freed up
our Land Management Bureau staff to
spend more time this has been something
that's like we manage it when we have
time or when a problem comes up and we
have to address it so our current
administrator for the Land Management
Bureau very detail oriented she has
spent time visiting all of the permitted
sites I don't know if she's got to all
of them but she's tried to get to all of
them to re-engage with these uh
permites uh and I would say in this past
year that the fees that we collected
probably did not cover much of her time
in
general all right so maybe we need
higher fees here so
um how about um commissioner we ask you
to get together with um either the
commissioner of Dees or the state G
geologist or both and and
make a plan for what you want to do um
and we can maybe support you with
legislation um if you get it to us uh by
the end of October kind of thing all
right I can do that all right thank you
all right other
questions here
nope okay any
others that are that are
forc none that are mine right do we see
any no should we go back to the
beginning yeah the next Canon we're
getting to Canon Mountain this one has
the
233s plus 104 and 105 okay all right
so all right we are on page
five Canon Mountain ski account that
sounds like an
important Brian I'll let you introduce
this one sure uh good afternoon everyone
I'm Brian Wilson I'm the director of the
division of Parks and
Recreation uh the Canon Mountain ski
accounts is um uh two um accounting
units um that um are part broad part of
our of the state park fund um that are
isolated out to um um
um specifically on the operate the ski
and winter Recreation components of uh
uh within frankone not State Park which
is Canon Mountain ski area uh the resort
and the um operation of the aerial
Tramway uh within the uh the two
different accounting units uh one is uh
primarily the uh 3303 that's the the
operations unit uh which is you know the
staff uh maintenance equipment
operations and then the 3704
uh unit is our concession and Retail uh
functions which include like our ski
school our rental shop uh the
concessions agreements that we have uh
which we contract out uh by and large
for uh food and beverage and uh other
retail operations uh year round
they also get money from the Hampton
Beach meters which yet is a pretty
significant amount of money that's
listed here but found in
105 yeah so if I may just just clarify
uh how that works so the the there's a
ski account and the park account those
those two components which make up
ultimately what they call the Park fund
so the ski account is confined to what
director Wilson just described which is
accounting in 3703 which is the
operations 3704 which is the retail and
concessions that's the ski account 7300
which is Hampton meters is part of the
broader service Park group of accounting
units which includes 3720 which is
service park operations 7300 which is
Hampton meters those go together uh to
comprise the Park account so although
related ultimately under under the the
park operations system um the Hampton
meters function is a is a component of
the service Park account versus the
Canon ski account I just wanted to
clarify that for you just so you
understood
that but that money doesn't go to the
the Canon Mountain it goes to the summer
activities are we talking about Hampton
meters yes Hampton meters
supports the park operation system
service park operations system um not
directly the Canon Mountain operations
system so first of all should we create
another dedicated fund because you're
you're reporting to us like they're two
separate funds state park account number
33 and then the second one
um one is Canon and one is others well I
don't know well they're both under 26
and a3i they're both under RSA 612
number
33 but you'll notice one is described as
the Canon Mountain ski account and one
is described as the state park account
right and within the state park account
you'll notice that notated in the
detailed activity section 7300 which is
Hampton meters is captured in that yes
in that
account oh I see but this is all Canon
mountain right it doesn't include the
other parks around the state uh the
first part of the discussion yes Canon
Mount you're discussing only the Canon
Mountain ski account yes that contains
only the Canon Mountain
activities and the second one includes
all of the other Parks correct because
that wasn't at all clear yes and please
remember that we don't charge at all of
our Parks some of our Parks don't that
we do charge at don't create a big
enough Revenue to support themselves so
that that State Park fund where the
Hampton tolls are part of that really
helps us support the entire
[Music]
system do do money collected at other
state parks go to Canon or vice
versa no
no no the the the funding the revenue
collected at state parks around the
state stay within the service Park
system the park ski
account only Revenue collected at the
Canon Mountain ski
area is in the actual Canon Mountain ski
account okay so in this Canon Mountain
account you're spending you're receiving
and spending $10 million a year
approximately yes roughly um but all
those expenses are at Canam correct and
all the revenue is from skiers yes okay
okay with all right so maybe that should
be its own dedicated fund without
mixing in in fund 33 all the other stuff
yeah I agree
okay well that's something we can do
right yeah
okay um
question yes Senator we have other funds
that only have one number but have two
sheets in the book right yes which this
would lend itself to without any
legislative action right well there's
there's a there's statutory uses and
then there's how we account for it in
the accounting system so different
agencies choose to put things in
different accounting units or you can
see all the narrative that describes all
the back and forth between all the
accounting units that's up to the agency
but we just need to follow the statutory
uses of the underlying statute and if it
doesn't require multiple dedicated funds
the agency can choose to use the
accounting system to do whatever
internal calculations they need to do
let me try to translate that and see
what I heard okay okay if they use
different accounting units even though
it only has one dedicated fund number
it'll do
what you really want it to do without
any other modification at all no change
in the RSA no anything else just you
guys picking a different accounting
number all right well it's I guess it
would be up if if if it's causing a
strain on their uh tracking then there
may be a benefit to give it its own RSA
612 ID number which gives it its own
place in the book but I mean I that's
why I defer the agency if they're if
they're working the accounting system
which is robust enough to handle all
this it's just this book is at a much
higher
level yeah to to be clear so I think
they're grouped correctly in terms of
the accounting units so the ski account
there are two accounting units grouped
for the park operations this park
account there are actually four
accounting units that are grouped I
think the confusion here is they're both
both of those accounts while grouped
separately in the accounting system are
identified with the same ID number RS ID
number RSA ID number so if they had
different say idea numbers that would
make it a little clearer on your part to
be able to see 33 is Canon Etc 34 is
Parks Etc if that's I think that's what
we're talking about yes yeah okay but
there's there's another problem that 33
isn't Canon it's Canon ski
area and the the other one is Canon and
all the other parks in there and canon
in its uh function as the rest of the
Mountain of can so if I'm understanding
I think what you're referring to is
Canon mountain in the winter is the
canon skia in the summer is francon not
state park is that yeah okay yes that
that's confusing I I agree with that as
well um that's kind of a more difficult
thing to to identify because you have
summer operations
occurring and going to One account and
winter operations occurring and going to
a different account um but that that
that's really the only exception in this
case that makes that creates a little
bit of that
confusion so you're saying that
accounting units 373 and
3704 are only for
skiing they're they're only for skiing
they only with the exception no with the
exception of Summer operations on Canon
Mountain for the operation of the tram
but everything else that occurs up there
is Franconia Notch State
Park oh okay yes that all stays in the
service Park account okay so the tram is
always part of this cannon ski thing
correct right I see
not sure if I answered the question but
I think you can do it either way need a
field trip pretty much it's up to you
guys if you want to change you're G to
have to come ask us okay
yeah I I looked at this and I thought
that we had these four income sections
all coming into Cannon Mountains
mountain basically to keep camon
Mountain alive right and which is the
one that you took
sonap right and and and because they're
designated with the same ID of number 33
it does appear that way and I understand
now what you're what you're talking
about
yes maybe maybe I'll talk to somebody on
the resources committee that makes sense
if any of them I think you have in the
past changed the names of the ID numbers
and I think we did did that with pasas a
year or two ago if you wanted to clarify
the naming convention but uh yeah I I
think that yeah if you want it crystal
clear you would give it two ID numbers
and call it what you want to call it and
that would clarify it yeah yeah
okay all right so the second half of
this one is
Parks so that's ACC counting
unit uh 3701 3 72
3722 Etc right there's a lot of them
that's
correct
okay and it's all the state parks yeah
yeah okay including and
mountain in it right other including
Franconia State Park yes okay
all right so
um so this
fund seems to again match revenue and
expenses quite
well
yeah with with a fairly sizable
cushion but not
excessive I had a note that the Au
numbers were sometimes wrong in the
report but maybe that's because I wasn't
understanding what went
where
yeah okay so for if I could just say the
balance here is really important to us
if there's a rainy summer for example
still want to pay our
employees um and uh and so I'm proud of
of this balance and would like to keep
it
sure yeah it looks like uh you have some
years where you have a little excess and
some years where yeah expenses are a
little
high let's talk about that why why did
expenses go up I is that mostly the the
increase in salaries yes um we um absorb
the 12% wage increases across the the
whole division here and um with without
any general funding support so uh that's
that's one factor uh in addition to that
uh with kind of the um um increase in
visitation Trends really Nationwide and
outdoor
recreation uh the um slight change in uh
climate with our shoulder Seasons
seeming to be ever expanding uh the
demand on the park system is um no
longer a memorial day through Labor Day
operation so we've had to build out
Staffing structure and other resources
to uh meet that demand so that has also
pushed um kind of uh an increased burden
on on on the expenditure side so we need
to increase some fees then well we have
been doing that incrementally over the
last uh year or so um we went to we got
approval through the fiscal committee uh
last year to uh increase the um Hampton
meters account so that again that that
goes back into this fund um after costs
um so we we've increased the parking
meters cost we um Revisited our
Campground fee structure increased that
at approximately 20% uh last year really
the main uh thing that's left now is uh
to contemplate his dayuse visitation uh
so that's where you know Park admissions
where we're collecting uh Park Park fees
and we've been looking at that and
studying that and there there was a
there was a bill last session on that
and they'll be actually there the um
rr&d is taking that up a study committee
I believe they kick that off next week
so we'll be kind of tracking that um and
um hopefully working with them on some
solutions here to um keep our our goal
really here is to try to you know with
in our self-funding model is to keep
costs as as as as low as we can for
folks to be able to come and camp and
visit the parks um but also because we
don't get general fund support we need
to make sure that we're we're we're
tracking uh very closely on on the whole
picture here so that we can remain um in
this solvent State here and that fund
balance there is is nice to be able to
have and to look at knowing that we've
got a little bit of of cushion there for
years where we go in One Direction or or
the other or on occasion there's certain
opportunities that that come across that
are kind of a once in a generation thing
for that we would want to um take
advantage of and then there's the
weather which is our toughest
challenge okay so but it sounds like
you're that's all in progress now this
is your comment yes yeah um no not over
there oh yeah that that was my
misunderstanding okay gotta I was trying
to
simplify a long I understand okay other
questions about fund
33 well I'm wondering do you have any
place in the the um fishing game on
Rescue operation problem um do we have a
role in in that um yes um in certain
parks and places we we are pretty
prevalent in in inner operations with
them primarily Mount madno um generally
speaking our our staff Park staff are
the First on scene uh for pretty much
any rescue uh on the mountain um because
we're there all of the time um so while
fishing game may be in the area or have
to come from somewhere outside we're
usually the first to hear about it and
the first to respond uh similarly uh
Mount Washington that that occurs um as
well too um but I mean it comes up all
the time at at different places where um
we we work uh hand inand with them uh
for for rescue stuff and then we also
have a lot a lot of uh interaction
relative to um enforcement and oversight
of the trail
system question represent W now that the
search and rescue fund is healthy from
the I safety pass do you does your staff
get any piece of that in it's rescue
operations no we don't what funds that
the the the help um that's a fishing
game fund so I'm not I know what what
what funds are yeah are um fees fees for
visiting a park so if somebody pays to
go hike Mount manad and they're paying
to park um that's funding the staff that
are there and um so that's a re source
that that is covered under that
similarly to Ocean rescue you know we
you know several hundred rescues happen
every year along the Sea Coast from our
lifeguard staff um so while it might not
be in the back country or on top of a
mountain it's still um life or death and
um those those costs are collected
through you know at the seos parking
fees question
other questions no okay let's go on
to um what's next
60 are these
groups no
60 is i' I'd regard it as a oneof oh
okay but I think it does it can be
grouped with a few other things I mean
do you want to do you have others that
you deal with that you we could get you
done sort of yeah a long list of them
here I'm just struggling to um back
and number referencing do you have this
report this 36 page yeah so we're just
going numerically here so there's 60
page except for the groupings that are
really
obvious yeah sorry Mr chair the the memo
they were instructed to follow the order
of the big book so they're not in the
same order as what you're looking at I
see based on how we
normally is in the order of when the
dedicated fund was created
oh or it made sense actually for a while
because we oh it's not in the order of
created all of these numbers from
scratch 22 years ago something like that
yeah the the book is in the order of the
RSA ID number with in the agency itself
so that this agency has a section of the
book and it starts with 9 all right so
that's that really can't be changed it
has nothing to do with how they
coordinate their divisions I see the RSA
number I have a key
here there you go all right so the RSA
number it's not I think you wanted to go
to 104 right
uh six we haven't done 60 yet that's
conservation plate
fund right but I thought in the Park
theme right in the Park theme the Park
theme I thought 104 was next okay that's
good all right 104 Capital Canam
Mountain Capital Improvements yeah i'
put that
one on there all right and I believe
that that is just for Canon Mountain
correct yes so so the Canon Mountain
Capital Improvement fund
um was established when um um the lease
of Mount sopy um was was was established
so uh under that uh lease agreement um
revenues um from Mount snipy um go to
this Canon Mountain Capital Improvement
fund which is specific to uh Capital
Improvement projects um and there is a
Canon Mountain advisory uh committee
um who oversees the uh um administration
of those funds so they meet two to three
times a year um and review the financial
statements from Mount sopy and the the
the revenue that is generated for that
that goes into this fund and our team at
Canon Mountain generate a list of uh
Capital needs um and we we um work to
you know keep up with the capital there
um there's a essentially it's a $6
million line of credit that U we have a
bonding Authority um to to have a a
revolving Bond um so the the revenue
from Canon Mountain pays down the
balance of that and then we um determine
which you know projects are going to
happen on on the next cycle and fund
them through this
Source how is the revenue divided
between this fund and the other
one and and um and the Canon uh the
Canon section um there's no revenue from
sopi that goes into the operating budget
of Canon oh this is Sun I'm sorry this
is just I see yeah I think the confusion
was you mentioned Canon Mountain as the
source of Revenue um sopy is the source
of revenue for this yeah I was but it's
yeah under funding source number one
Canon
Mountain yeah is this restricted to
Canon Mountain if you ran out of things
to do we will never run out of things to
do at Canon Mountain um um in fact it's
it's quite the opposite where where the
the Six Million uh bonding limit is is
is is not really able to to keep Pace
well really more the the annual revenue
that we get from sunap ranges somewhere
between four to $600,000 a year
depending depending on the year um so
um that's generally about how much we're
trying to um um target for Capital
Improvement projects on any given
Year yes represent J is that 400,000 uh
gross or
net that that's gross revenue is only
400,000 from um no so um Chris can help
me here there's a couple different
components of that yeah so let me just
to clarify
that service needs to be paid um so The
Debt Service typically represents a
component of principal and interest so
in this case snipy right now we're
generating it's a little more it's
probably we've been doing pretty well
been coming in somewhere around 700
,000 um but what happens is when we use
that money to pay the debt service if
the debt service is
$600,000 for the for a particular
year only a portion of that $600,000
will now become available again for
rebonding in this case it's typically
somewhere in the $ four to $500,000 a
year range so we pay
600,000 a portion of that pays interest
so we're we're trending somewhere around
having on a yearly basis available as
long as we maintain that Debt Service
payment schedule somewhere around
$400,000 a year but we do have to
monitor how much we continue to
incur um to make sure that we don't get
to a point where our debt service per
year exceeds the amount of Revenue that
that sunap is generating we haven't
reached that threshold we're we're still
safe um so we're able to continue to
keep redrawing that principle to
maximize that million doll authorization
but we do have to actively monitor that
depending on uh the ability of centipede
to generate that Revenue which we
receive a percentage of 2016 was a great
example the winter was virtually
non-existent um and it it was before I
became commissioner just to know
yes uh and uh significant drop in
Revenue that year did cause a bit of a
deficit for a a short period of time but
we were able to regain that very recover
that very quickly yes representative W
have we had any projection on the um
projected life of the aerial
Tramway that'll be very expensive when
that needs to be so yes so we're on year
three or four of noodling the future of
the tram um and uh you know raised the
um the awareness that the future of the
tram was coming the the life expectancy
of the tram was coming to an end soon um
so we started this conversation three or
four years ago through the capital
budget process um we explored arpa um
that didn't pan out um we were allocated
188 million um in the last budget for
the tram and that was okay for us
because we are all of our estimates at
the at the time we did estimates um
predicted about a 20 to $25 million
ticket for the whole thing the P shebang
so 18 million from the the state
allocation we could Bridge the rest we
could figure out how to get to the rest
when we did go out to bid um the one bid
that came back was a total of 33 million
so we can't do 18 to we we're just not
in a position to bridge that so we're
revisiting um options we have a couple
of of I of ideas and some strategies
that we're working through with um
commissioner Charlie Arling house and
his team at DPW uh right now the tram is
evaluated regularly it is safe for
operation um we're looking forward to a
wonderful Fall Foliage season um but we
do recognize that um pretty soon we're
going to have a component that's
Irreplaceable because of its age um and
so we need to come up with a a plan
sooner rather than later it's a top
priority of ours thank
you thanks Senator Ros thank you so
Canon mountain is skiing in the winter
and the tram in this summer and
everything else is state is Franconia
state park Canon mountain is part of
Franconia not state park right
but I I guess I'm wondering why in the
capital Improvement
fund
um some of the money not all of the
money
is going to the Canon Mountain ski area
and trm some of it is going apparently
to
Franconia State Park and you know where
I'm coming from on this which is the
continuing higher skiing fees on the
military and
seniors and so I'm just wondering why
we're not spending all of the Canon
Mountain Capital Improvement fund on
either the ski area or the
Tramway but some is apparently going to
Fran coni and not State Park um no so we
we are spending everything that is
available at Canon so maybe maybe it
would be better said this way Franconia
Notch State Park resides on Canon
Mountain on Canon Mountain during the
winter we have ski operations on Canon
mountain and during the summer the park
is the primary function on that mountain
the Tramway also exists on Canon
mountain and that functions primarily in
the summer it does not typically
function for any kind of Revenue
generating purposes in the
winter all of the money being used
through this bonding opportunity that
exists is devoted to infrastructure that
resides on Canon
mountain now it could be for winter
operational needs so you know snow
makings
pumps various types of
infrastructure it could also be used for
other infrastructure that may be used
during summertime um
the the statute itself is descri it
instructs the revolving fund shall be
used for Capital Improvements for the
ski area and related State Park
facilities at counton
Mountain so it can be done for
both um which is typically P most of the
time it's been it's been used for the
winter operations that is where a lot of
the infrastructure spending needs need
to occur up on that mountain I can't
think of a single project that um that
we've there or that um Canon Mountain
advisory commission has authorized for
that that is outside of the footprint of
the Canon Mountain ski area um we don't
do anything you know down the road at
The Flume or the the campground or
anything it's really strictly for snow
making lift maintenance the Tramway the
physical buildings that are part of the
footprint of the ski area like The
Lodges or the ski school facility um and
other supporting infrastructure really
within the footprint of the ski area but
not not to the greater Franconia not
State Park
yes thanks I appreciate that but it
seems like the statute would allow you
to do
that and maybe we should look at that so
that we didn't have to
keep raising skiing fees on seniors by
20 plus perc every year um well so the
our our fees are really separate from
the capital Improvement Fund in in the
sense that there that th those are
strictly being um part of of our
operating funds to cover our operating
costs which is a separate Bud budget now
you could make the argument that the
more that we let something go and and
don't put it into our operating budget
as far as like preventative maintenance
or something then that becomes a a
capital item certainly um um so I I I
see your point there relative to the
that extra couple of words there within
the statue saying in other Park related
infrastructure um so that that that
could be contemplated but I I can um our
position has been that that is really
completely isolated to this to uh the
components of the ski area um and other
functions and infrastructure needs that
we have throughout greater francon not
State Park we would put through a
capital uh budget
request other
question
okay all right
good
um now does it really make sense to be
in continuous debt
here because you're saying that you
can't
borrow um as much as you're paying in
right you're always paying interest
so
um if you're just sitting on this 18
million allocated for this use could we
could we pay this off and and gain some
interest right now that we're not going
to pay uh well first I just want to make
sure we're clear the 18 million you're
referring to that's for the tram for the
tram that was allocated through the
budget process specifically for the uh
purpose of investing in the in the tram
refurbishment The Six Million I'm sorry
the the $6 million that is bonded um yes
if there was if there was no debt on
that Bond and that $6 million was
available that could be used to support
support that project that is true is is
that what you're right so my question is
well maybe the other way to think about
it is is the interest we're getting on
this 18 million greater or less than
than the interest we're paying on the 6
million in
debt do we
know the 18 million if it was in the
capital budget would be borrowed when
the when the project was started oh was
it capital budget money yeah yeah
correct so it's oh it's not yet it's not
yet borrowed it's not sitting there okay
okay I'm sorry I thought you meant that
18 million was allocated out of the
operating budget but only until it was
needed and then they would Bond it right
so it's in House Bill 25 right yes uh
actually this particular funding was in
house bill to it was in the trailer bill
it was not specified but it was intended
to be a
capital so it wasn't borrowed it has not
yet been borrowed no it has only been
appropriated
it will be borrowed if we can ultimately
Bor in house B operating County units
Sor it's the Appropriations in one of
your operating it is in one of our
operating account so it's sitting in
pulled cash right now under the
treasurer's cash accounts right sorry
yes they do have it in
cash yeah they got General funds the
point right yeah yeah so it has it it's
not really typical capital budget
dollars if it's coming from a house bill
to appropriation it's likely General
correct so yes I I stand correct on that
that it was allocated under an operating
budget account it was not allocated
specific to the capital budget itself
that's correct okay right it's just for
a capital in nature type of item but
that's right not capital budget funding
so yeah sitting in a bank account
earning interest with all of our other
state funds it is not isolated so we
wouldn't be able to tell you you know
exactly what saying was capital budget
we don't right we don't spend it till we
need correct then we borrow it on a when
I talk to the state treasurer I'll ask
that question of her all right thank you
all right let's go
on what's next here well I think we're
going backwards we're going backwards
yeah because we skipped the conservation
plate fund I
believe and then well should we go
forwards to to more um State Park type
stuff yeah yeah is there you're the only
one who knows what state park stuff
is wow parking facilities you guys can
go in any order you want we'll keep up
okay parking facilities at Hampton
Beach yeah
105 Hampton
meters yeah okay page 14 in the hand up
okay yeah yeah that is a park thing okay
not a Canyon mountain 1500
spaces and so this is basically a source
of Revenue yes yes for most of the other
state it's a source of Revenue and it's
also um set up as a um bonding payback
mechanism as well too for the uh the
seaw wall uh along Ocean Boulevard at
North Beach um so um there there we
there's um been bonding projects for
that in the past where out of this fund
uh $200,000 goes comes out uh each year
to pay down uh the balance on that Bond
and then the re remaining funds would
cover cost of the operating expenditures
relative to our parking Enterprise uh
throughout the Sea Coast um I think it's
worthwhile noting as well to that this
operation although it's um or no
actually I'm going to confuse things
here now because it's it although we
have parking meters at other parks along
the Sea Coast this fund is specific to
Hampton Beach State
Park there also a pavilion there that's
paid
for um
that the well the sea shell complex I
don't I don't know Chris that any of the
um capital projects of the the Hampton
Redevelopment that is not part of the
bonding that that this is It's
specifically to the seaw wall I believe
is that yes so the the amount and again
we have a situation where for example a
fund uh ID
286 which is on page 27 of the handout
uh it's called the Hampton Beach Capital
Improvement fund within this fund was
created I believe around 2012 it was
created to manage The Debt Service
primarily what on what was ultimately
bonded and expended for the seawall
effort there is a residual Debt Service
that still exists in there although it
has waned over the years it's getting
smaller and smaller
however by Statute requirement Hampton
meters continues to contribute $200,000
a year directly out of its Revenue
earnings to fund the debt service within
the Hampton Beach Capital Improvement
fund because that amount is far
exceeding the amount of actual Debt
Service incurred on a yearly basis
within that Capital Improvement fund
the capital Improvement fund has
actually built a
balance um over the last few years and
uh in 20123 we actually used a
substantial portion of that uh close to
$300,000 to fund uh some Capital
Improvements that Brian could elaborate
I don't remember specifically what it
was um most of the things that were're
funding on Capital Improvements uh
relative at Hampton right now are storm
damage respon response so um that that
is a challenge to keep Pace
with so so Hampton meters does support
the capital Improvement fund that was
created for for Hampton Beach uh in a in
a fairly substantial way right
now so are you saying the 200,000 should
be adjusted to something else something
smaller no um no I'm just merely
pointing out that it exceeds the amount
of debt service that is still being paid
on the remaining amount of what was
bonded okay but but it doesn't but you
also have these other
expenses for for Capital
Improvement right I mean if you have to
patch uh potholes
or fixed parking meters or something
like that right yeah as as as expenses
come along particularly in this case as
Brian pointed out you know there's been
significant storm damage issues that
have occurred over the last few years it
has actually been a good thing to the
extent that by building up a balance
within this Hampton Beach Capital
Improvement fund by putting $200,000 a
year over there um against a Debt
Service that much less than that we were
able to leverage that builtup balance to
actually
fund some some Capital infrastructure
needs that needed to occur on the on the
Sea Coast and not have delays on fixing
the damage
yes there is an advantage to being able
to do
that okay
um and um go ahead are you going to have
to extend the seaw wall because that
that those storms are going to keep
coming I defer that question to director
Wilson um maybe not in our lifetimes uh
but uh perhaps someday yes we we we
every year we seem to have uh greater
impacts newer impacts we're working very
closely with the Department of
Transportation they have within their
10-year Transportation plan a major
Redevelopment of Ocean Boulevard um and
we're really working closely with that
because it it all com contemplates
realignment of the roadway in
conjunction with the sidewalks and the
seaw wall and as you all know it's we
have a very narrow Corridor uh there to
be able to work with um and um you know
it's not just the ocean side of the
things but we have the marsh uh to the
West as well too which is all part of
the same uh system that uh you know
continues to um congest on on everything
there so that's going to be uh a
continued area of vulnerability for the
state all right so um don't expect the
200,000 away yeah so the what you're
talking about this annual Debt Service
that's this $80,000
roughly I guess uh if you're referring
to the uh the table under 286 yes yeah
on page 28 on page 28 yes so The Debt
Service uh is is you can see it's it's
slowly incrementally decreasing every
year but yes it's in the $880,000 a year
range it went it's actually down to 73
and we expect that to continue to Trend
until that debt service is paid which
means the $200,000 going into this
account will just acrew as available
funding uh to support Capital
Improvements now do you have a more
General Capital fund for all
parks nothing more than the normal
capital budget that
we seek to to to have oh so you go to
how Bill 25 25 yes right that's correct
I see gotcha
um again because I was thinking
that if you had less here you could have
more
for uh your regular Park expenses
right yeah yeah I suppose it's I guess
you could look at it two different ways
I mean it seems as though the need in
both areas is is great um so I'm not
sure if if I could qualify advantage or
disadvantage either way I would again
defer to to director Wilson on that are
you are suggesting that if the the
200,000 was 150 was
150,000 that that extra would go back
into uh Park fund or our operating
budget U so to speak um yes um but um
the mechanism how it's currently sent
works for us as you know just as well I
think um because there are you know
Beach is one of our Flagship parks and
there's always going to be
infrastructure needs there I think
structurally how this was set up um
helps us um kind of be able to be a
little bit more Nimble with that capital
account to specifically address um
capital projects now they are always
going to be smaller in nature of only
just a few hundred thousand doll at a
time probably unless we somehow were
able to go over a long period of time
without having to access that at all um
but our Park revenue and the revenue
stream are never going to be able to
keep Pace with the um both our operating
expenses and our and the capital needs
okay all right so let's say we're done
with whatever this one
is other
questions all right so this is um there
were two Hampton Beach things 286 right
okay so we finished 286 fin 286 that
one's
287 why isn't two wait
a yeah 286 is uh Capital Improvements
and equipment for half so why isn't it
in the
spreadsheet it's in the spreadsheet
under
286 page five page five at the
top right no
all
right oh okay sorry page 13 at the
bottom all right oh she her print out
was different than mind sorry better
order yeah well that would require
rewriting the dedicated funds yeah let's
make a committee to do the and I already
done that once all right
so went from all right where we were on
the parking meters all right so this was
number page 14 yeah number 104 go back
to where we haven't been
before there's one more Hampton beach3
on page 25 of the
memo two Anon Beach commission yeah 223
223 yeah funds for the master
plan okay GI and
donations which
is all right it's page 25 of
36 and it's page 13 of this one gifts
and
donations um Hampton Beach master plan
fund this the town of Hampton and the
state of with the state of New Hampshire
it's collaborative okay gr Emer I think
called me about this one make sure it
gets
fun all right yes um the Hampton each
area commission um does great work it is
it is a very uh important collaborative
group with stakeholders including Dot
and dncr uh and the town of Hampton
among others um um that um has worked um
to do the Hampton Beach master plan
which was really kind of the first phase
to um bring the realization of the
Redevelopment project that is Hampton
Beach State Park now um which um is you
know was a catalyst for um you know
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars of economic impact and and
development in in the C Coast Community
um and they continue to do work now
they've they've um started you know
they're collectively working on other
resiliency plans um both you know that
the town of Hampton locally is doing um
but also bringing back to you know
collaborate with uh the state agencies
mainly do and um
dncr um and um as you can see here their
their sources of funding are starting to
to to dry up here but um so that I I I I
believe that they'll be looking for some
additional appropriation uh at some
point so they can continue to do their
work and um our agency serves as sort of
a um an oversight to the administrative
functions of that
um all
right so this one
um all right so where did they get the
150 ,000 last
year yeah I can speak to that so this
was uh this was related to uh money that
was allocated again uh through
hb2 uh it was made available for the
purpose of conducting a feasibility
study um which the money passed through
this account
or I'm sorry was it the accessibility
yeah one was there was an accessibility
and then a feasibility yes that's
correct so both the $20,000 figure and
the $150,000 figure were passed through
uh the budget process and I believe
there's a report due at the end of
October right Brian yes they're they're
uh currently um working with us on the
facilitation of the um accessibility
study which was um the result of uh uh
legis
last last year um relative to the um
discussion about the um construction of
a pier at Hampton Beach um so that that
ended up turning into an accessibility
study which is um nearing the end of
their
work so if we're just going to put stuff
in the budget why do we need a dedicated
fund well this this money was through us
to this Commission
if I understand
correctly yeah correct the the
fundamental purpose of the dedicated
fund was support through the Hampton
Beach master plan efforts that as I
understand are typically ongoing at any
given point in time um this was just
used it was a mechanism that was
available for them
to put the funding in so they could
perform these particular one-off actions
these studies that they wish to perform
yes I'm sorry Senator Ros well I
following up on your question we
frequently make Appropriations to
departments that are pass through why do
we need a dedicated fund for the
feasibility study that's already been
done and an accessibility study that's
just about
done why is the department recommending
that we keep this
fund again just to to if I could clarify
this the receipt of those two amounts
that were allocated through the budget
process the $20,000 for feasibility and
the $150,000 for
accessibility those could also just as
easily have been allocated to their own
accounting units they would have been
created as an accounting unit they would
have been expended they would have been
gone so you wouldn't even have seen them
pass through this dedicated fund so
assuming let's assume that were the case
there's still this dedicated fund which
supports the Hampton Beach master plan
effort the reason why this fund should
continue is because as long as there is
a Hampton Beach master plan effort going
on and an opportunity to fund that those
efforts this dedicated fund will
continue to serve its purpose as it was
intended does that make
sense well it does except there's
$197 in it which yes they they were very
vigorous in their spending in the last
fiscal year but uh that that doesn't
mean that there won't be new money and
new donations new Revenue put into the
account that ultimately will continue to
be used for its intended purpose you can
thank Nancy styles for that 9197 she
likes to make sure that that commission
has work to do and that there's
Consultants on hand uh to keep them
all working towards the work the great
work that they're
doing but why is
Hampton Beach the it's not even a
municipality on the only recipient of
help with their master
plan because it's somewhat of a state
park they have more traffic than any
place else town and it's a state park
fire I started to go there once and 2
and a half miles away the traffic was
crawling I turned
around if it if it helps we ultimately
we're really considered a Fiscal Agent
under these
circumstances we're not really
facilitating the purpose of of the plan
of the of the
Fundy with this more L all right
223 all right so that's it for Hampton
Beach how about State
Parts well we still have probably a
bunch
309 BR yeah there's
p uh
20 29
of
36 at the
bottom St Park gifts and
donation nobody's giving us
right well I spend
spending Chris I don't know if I can
defer to you on this one one that uh a
little less familiar with the
utilization of the history here yes so
as you can see the the state park gifts
and donations account was established
some time ago obviously to receive gifts
and donations from
patrons um in the years in recent years
um there is there does continue to be a
gift and donation effort that is ongoing
for the park system however it appears
that the way that we set that up is it's
part of the overall uh opport it's part
of it's set up for patrons non-patrons
anybody who wishes to donate to the park
can donate
directly to the to the state parks
account so in doing so the mechanisms
for example online donation giving when
they choose to donate uh those money are
are funnel into the state park account
directly so so this account has been
retained for the purpose of donations
that are brought to us separately
typically for a specific purpose uh
something that somebody wishes to
identify and thus donate for so we
haven't seen a lot of that activity or
we have not used this account for that
activity in some time um I don't know if
that's something that needs to be
discussed internally as far as whether
we should be leveraging ing the purpose
of this this account uh to
clarify when what types of donations
would go into this account versus the
receipt of donations that we're
receiving directly from folks that go on
for example buy you know admissions
tickets or make Park camp reservations
and at the same time say yeah plus I
want to give $25 to the park so it all
just gets put in as part of their fees
it goes directly into the state park
account and we don't see it flow through
this donation
account is there uh limits on how much
those kind of donations can be there are
no limits per se uh but any donation
over
$2,500 also needs to be approved through
the governor Council
process but that would be true in either
case yes right so
maybe uh this isn't needed and we can
just put the balance into the other
account into this directly into the
state ski account so it certainly would
be possible I'd defer director Wilson if
he has an opinion about that one way or
the
other
um I I I think that that seems like
relatively um benign action I don't
think that that would have any big
impact yeah this is I will say this is
this is a relatively old this is an old
account I think this was created created
at a time when donations primarily were
people writing checks giving
cash um and now of course you know
modern technology donations can be made
very easily very quickly and typically
cash and checks are just not seen so uh
there may be it may make sense at this
point to consider um eliminating this I
I had a political event and I had a
friend who wanted to go and I and he
says how do I make a donation and I said
well just bring a check and he says I
haven't written a check in three years
you know it's
like all right yes um representative M
me so if you um if we deleted this fund
it would lapse into the whichit park
account
33 yes it would it would go in into the
into the park account it go into the
3702 is the actual account that
maintains the the park
balance 37 point over here yeah just
real quick it may have been set up
because often donations uh come with a
deed of gift and they may have done that
for tracking purposes so let's say
somebody gave a gift to fix the Hampton
Beach you know
wall or something um I'm sure that the
trust division would want to know that
that money was being tracked for that
purpose uh thank you yes that would be
another good example of why you would
maintain a separate account I'd be
curious um and I guess again this might
require just internal discussion I I
haven't seen anything like that and I've
been here 10 years so I I I'm not sure
apparently in 2021 2022 somebody gave
$15,000
for a specific thing yeah yeah m a money
donation
yeah well you you spent
$115,000 and then you raised
15,000 so so that was a specific item it
looks like it likely but I would have to
go back and look specifically what that
was I'm not that have been
Trails before my time so I have to I can
I can get the history on that for you
that so so maybe we keep the account but
move the
money it's possible yeah sure
okay um yes representative Jenny again
um so if this account goes away and
somebody wanted to make a donation where
would it go uh so I can speak to that I
thank you for asking that question
because I was going to make a point that
although you're not seeing any activity
here we actually are seeing quite a bit
of generosity out in in the park system
uh Within the last um uh couple of years
we've um um stood up um multiple
different ways of making donations you
can go on our website there's a button
right there that says make a donation um
and so you can go through um our online
portal this the same system for our
Campground and dayuse reservation
systems will collect that um
additionally at many of our uh Park
areas particularly the ones where we
don't charge a fee um we are um if you
recall kind of the Old Iron Ranger Green
things where you would stick your money
in the slot we've been converting those
to more advanced mechanisms with QR
codes and other things and within the
last year um we're generating over
$100,000 um in online donations um and
and donations from the field so we're
we're seeing that that is being um um
utilized and and has been very effective
in generating additional re revenue for
us and we continue to try to expand that
program um particularly our into our
Trail Network is where we're really
thinking that there's some opportunity
there now as well
too okay well that that sounds good
because if there's other ways to donate
and I was going to suggest something on
the website which it sounds like you
already have then this does in my
opinion seem like it's obsolete at this
point yeah representative M the only
reason I can see for keeping this is the
difference between gifts and donations
and I never realized there was a
difference I thought it was just archaic
language on
but having this here if anybody looks at
those things sends a message that
nobody's giving
anything yeah okay so therefore we don't
want
okay
good all right so that's that's good
where are um are we at the end of state
parks
and did we did we Overlook anything in
between uh yes uh 108 is U Mount
Washington and then there's um a few
others beyond that as well too all right
let's go to 108 I separated Mount
Washington is I think a cluster
group that's on page 16 of
30 yeah 108 and 167
Mount Washington
commission so the uh 108 the Mount
Washington commission this is uh sort of
a a unique oneoff within the context of
the greater Park system where um a
individual Park Mount Washington state
park has it has under RSA it its own
oversight body and its own budgeting uh
its own budget mechanism outside of uh
the um State Park uh um State Park
account yeah so is this the auto road or
is that no it's uh we it's the summit of
Mount Washington is the is the state
park so uh we work very the um the um
members of the auto Road um and the Cog
Railway and other Summit Partners like
uh the Appalachian Mountain Club um
um um and the the Mount Washington
weather observ are are members of the
Mount Washington commission so that
Collective body meets uh very routinely
to um you know work through uh their
statutory requirements of kind of the
oversight and stewardship of of Mount
Washington State
Park uh the funding uh oh and that
commission has control of this account
yes
okay doing that right yeah
yeah there is one thing uh the purchase
from Dartmouth College ended in 2020 so
it doesn't really need to be in the
report are you saying Dartmouth owns the
Dartmouth owned it which is something
I'm I was surprised to oh to Dartmouth
yes I see from Dartmouth sold it to us
to to us over a long period and that
ended in 2020 yeah got and they have a
lot of money they probably shouldn't
have all right I
see all right so you don't see any need
for changes in this area yeah anybody oh
y Senator is thank
you they're not that many people on the
commission so I'm curious why the
expenses
are almost two and a half million
dollars a year so the commission is for
the uh advisory oversight body to the
operation of the summit uh so the summit
facilities the Sherman Adams Building uh
the communication facilities that are at
the summit all of the
Staffing um uh that goes on there the we
have our a wastewater treatment plan at
the summit so all of those operations
are what the what the operating budget
uh that's where our expenditures lie and
then uh um similar to the state parks
and Canon Mountain it is set up to be
self-funded in nature so um all of the
retail operation at the summit that we
the state park division manages um
concessions food sweatshirts everything
that you can imagine at the store at the
summer uh at The Summit in addition to
leases that come in for uh communication
Services uh and also leases with like
the weather uh the Mount Washington
Observatory uh the auto Road agreements
with the Cog all of that Revenue helps
uh offset uh the the the cost to operate
and manage the summit so it's not just
funding the commission no yes yeah the
commissions funding is very very simple
you know they they get uh Refreshments
at their meetings and um mileage of
reimbursement maybe and that's probably
the extent of what the the cost of that
group is yeah do they meet at The Summit
we are meeting at the summit this Friday
actually if you want to come we're going
to be in the tiptop house might be a
little chilly but uh we generally meet
offsite but uh gen once a year they do
like to try to get to the summit when
when the conditions are allowable so all
right but unlike your meeting they
apparently have
aha all right well um the that's
related because tiptop house is also at
the summit that's related to a private
fund for the tiptop which is 110 right
oh no one 567
all right so we we've been going um two
hours shall we take a a break of uh s
minutes or something for Bio break or
get a drink or how much longer are we
going to
go I think we're T to L if we're away
but I think we've covered a lot of it
okay we we'll take a short break but we
haven't gotten into libraries and things
like that yet and if you're not if you
don't want to take a
damage and loss no
um no I don't think there's anything I
need on that so I think you're
good you don't have any
damage probably but I'm sure you
do
e
e e
all right let's resume
here
okay all right I think we are on fund
number 60 um well you were going to go
back to tiptop First oh back to tiptop
since we're on Mount Washington yeah
okay where was
the
tip when yeah fund number
167 is that
it tiip top
house which is 16 which
is yeah so it's page 18 at the bottom of
36 all right
no expenses no
Revenue a little Revenue a tiny amount
of Revenue okay tell us about this
one um okay I'll let Brian talk about it
but just a little background um we're
currently in um in a in a phase of re
freshening up the tiptop house it's such
an attraction when you go up to Mount
Washington especially if it's a cloudy
day and you can't you don't have a view
it's something else to do when you're up
at the top um and uh it's an original
structure um and so we have invested um
some resources uh into sort of um
freshening it up rewiring it and
creating more of a museum experience in
this little building um and so I just
wanted to point out that I'll let Brian
speak to this specific fund but we might
be in a position um to spend a little
bit of money here and there to to
continue our uh reopening efforts at the
time right and also it says this is a
trust fund yes so so we really can't do
anything with yeah yeah so the yeah the
original um donation to to establish a
trust was $20,000 with it and so we
can't spend down below that principal
amount so as it says our strategy has
been to let it uh interest AC crew for a
few thousand dollars uh over a course of
a few years and then we'll do a project
or two there but I also think that
there's an opportunity here with
additional donations as a possibility
that once we realize um kind of the
revital ization of it and kind of the
reopening of it here that we have know a
mechanism here to hopefully generate
some more um philanthropy at the summit
okay very good
okay yeah shall we go back to number
110 which is number
60 well no this is the 110 is snowmobile
ohrv and snowmobiles is that par that is
under the division of Parks and
Recreation yes as well our our Bureau of
Trails um
um so uh These funds come come by come
way by way of um uh registration fees um
for uh snowmobiles and uh ohvs um passed
through uh the fishing game uh to us uh
for the administration of some of our
grant and aid programs um so portions of
those um those funds go that are
collected go back directly out to the
clubs and the groups who are uh
cooperatively managing those Resources
with
us what does unref unded gas tax
mean you don't have had to deal with
that yet yeah that that's a source of
funding that actually comes over uh from
from safety uh they we we get a portion
I believe we get onethird of the total
amount that is collected because it's
not used on roads yeah used by off-road
vehicles so you shouldn't pay the
road oh I
see well
it's it's an approximation of how much
there is they give it back for bolts
snowmobiles and Offroad gotcha because
they pay the gas tax when they buy their
gas right I see okay
yeah deal with the right Marina they
take care
of now um so this one's been gradually
growing it looks
like are you are you saving for a
particular purpose
or uh well this is a particular fund
that uh is used primar arily a large
portion of it is used to fund the grant
and aid program but it also does cover
all of the administrative costs of
running the
bureau
um so it has been it has been
building uh but again we
uh have certain limits that is to
say we are funded by fish and game for a
certain amount of money that's all that
we're able to receive that's how much is
is given out um so if we maintain
control of expenses well then the fun
the balance does does continue to
build I guess I'll just add uh the price
of maintaining these Trails has
increased
dramatically I'm learning so much about
culverts in this job um and engineering
and uh it's not it's not the same as you
know the 1980s the so mobile Club could
fix a bridge together over you know a
weekend uh these these uh storms and the
usage really creates expensive projects
so it is important for us to have
flexibility in how we're spending this
the recent storms this past year in
several spots in New Hampshire um have
created um damage on trails that is that
is really um you know upset a lot of
people and we're trying our best to
prioritize them but it's not it's not as
easy and simple as it used to be um also
I don't know this is a snapshot so a lot
of the funds that come through this
account we we go through and we kick
back as much as we can to the trail so
um you know
the we're not usually we're not always
sitting it looks like you're getting
ready to do a whole bunch of projects
this year because you encumbered 4
million plus bucks when you previously
had only been a million a year I
remember one
interesting thing that um we were
building a bridge and okay doesn't need
to be quite as strong as when it had
railroad going over it so why why we
spending so much well let take care of
the cable that runs through the railroad
right away but why don't we charge them
the cable company the phone company
whoever it was well when we bought the
right away from the railroad we didn't
buy the contract on the right away for
the phone
company so they the railroad still
collects from from the from them for the
RightWay but we have to maintain it who
put us in that deal I don't know they
should be replaced but they're long
[Music]
gone okay um are you in control of
snowmobile registration
fees or not no is that statute fishing
game fishing game oh fishing game okay I
see and they only give you a portion is
that right I see okay other questions oh
it works it works we're happy okay all
right that's
110 so now do we want to go back to
60 yeah all
right all right we'll go back to fund 60
accounting unit
345 what's the name is called um
conservation
plates okay and this
one is on page8 of
36 so this fund as you as you know um is
distributed among several
agencies um and this the conservation
fund predates the um reall or the
reconfiguration of this agency so
there's an allocation to the cultural
and there's an allocation um to dncr or
to what is now dncr so um there's a long
history of how each division has um set
up their granting process for this fund
it's been incredibly successful um we do
as a state spend I think 50,000 a year
on marketing for this and that's paid
off uh in dividends which is
fantastic everybody gets some
money I didn't know we had a state
con I'm
almost is it the
nonprofit no the commission that
oversees is there specific commission
that oversees this fund yeah are you are
you talking about the state conservation
committee one of the recipients of the
funding yeah there's a there's a
committee that that is convened that
also that I believe runs
the the management of the
fund you have a way of telling what
percentage goes to each of these groups
is it variable by year I didn't have
that on sorry yeah it's it's actually
fixed in statute so it started out so uh
we we receive 40% of the distribution uh
the fish and game department receives
20% uh and the state conservation
committee and New Hampshire land and
Community investment Authority I believe
they each get
20% or some one gets 20 and one gets
some amount so yes but it's it's defined
in statute it's very specific before we
were uh combined between the department
of culture resources and Dread we were
each receiving 20% so when we were
brought together as natural and cultural
resources we now receive 40% so we do
still the same amount that was allocated
um before we were
separate so why is there even a balance
here you would think a certain amount
came from the plates you're getting 40%
goes here 20 goes there you know Etc and
then it would be gone right yeah oh so
you're talking about the
table okay so this table is only depicts
the funds that are coming into our
department this is not a depiction of
the entire oh I see plate fund for the
state got we we can only speak to what
we're managing um so we have yes we've
been
spending and receiving healthy amounts
it has continued to to grow we just
received a distribution actually
yesterday of um $1.2
million for our agency Alone um so that
will be distributed within the agency
and then of course I'm sure there are
lots of plans to to spend those funds
yeah each of the divisions um work with
their staff to stand up Grant fund you
know granting
opportunities um if I could turn to the
team Ben you do a pretty aggressive job
pushing out these Grant dollars can you
give an example so uh we've been
spending over the last Ben Wilson
director of the division of historical
resources um we've been spending over
the last um about four or five years uh
260 240
$260,000 in uh grants uh to local
municipalities um those uh range about
between 10 and $20,000 a
piece got a band stand restored at my
town yes ex it's
beautiful okay so I see so so the point
is you can't sort of simply put this in
your Parks fund or something right
because it has to be used for these
kinds of St things right from the statue
okay all right very good other
questions no all right we're happy with
this one 6 eight since we're on historic
historic barns next
one so this fund was set up several
years ago um to administer a grant
program from the National Park Service
and it was uh geared
towards um sending grants out for the
restoration of agricultural buildings so
barns um blacksmith's shops chicken
coups um Carriage sheds those kinds of
things everything but the
Farmhouse um those monies were uh spent
and uh there has not been another uh
grant program from the National Park
Service since um during that time uh the
barn committee um was set up and uh to
this day meets quarterly and does an
annual trip to a farm um or multiple
farms uh in the month of July to um go
through a property help out a homeowner
uh Farm owner with advice on how to
repair um restore their buildings or
care for them or come up with adaptive
reuse Barns and agricultural buildings
in the state are likened to are the
rural versions of our Mills in our uh
cities and larger towns um and so at the
time that that Grant um fund was created
at the National Park Service at the
national level um it was recognized that
we were losing these buildings from our
uh landscape at a at an alarming rate um
and it was very successful I wish the
Park Service would step up again and do
it again um and if we were to receive
funds this is where they would be parked
so this committee doesn't have any
expenses or you pay for them out of
something else there's no expenses we
aren't allowed to supp they don't get
snacks at their meeting I was going to
say we don't allow we don't allow snacks
or bottles of water or
mileage or mileage to go to the barn
there's no mileage no it's a Frugal
group okay very they're Farmers yeah
Farm okay um so maybe we should get rid
of this one oh and there's one other
thing it says it's
doing it says that that they are
preparing to publish a second edition of
their book on how to restore barns uh
yes so uh John Porter uh who used to be
with uh UNH
extension um in their
um uh in their um uh Dairy and goat side
of their business um he um was the
author with with other folks editing uh
of the first uh New Hampshire Barn book
um that has since the second edition
actually has been published and um and
we're collecting funds that go into a
different account actually another um to
support uh further um publishing of that
book and edits to that for a third
edition probably within the next four to
five years a any of this go for covered
bridges uh no unfortunately not
um yeah so we ought to leave it alone in
case another rant comes in I gu and if
we took it away why would these people
keep driving around
visiting I mean they're they're
providing a good service for free for
somebody so that's true and we and we do
hope that um that there will be an
opportunity um to have Grant funds uh
for this purpose or a similar purpose
all right representative Jan um is there
you just said you to have some more
Grant funds is there a website or is
there something pointing people to it
because you know if there's something
that excites people about it they may
donate but if they don't know about it
nothing's going to happen uh so on the
tra I believe it's on the travel and
tourism uh website one of the products
that our committee worked very hard on
over the last two years is creating a
barn tour so much like a cheese tour or
an ice cream tour in the state um we've
developed uh there's a site and um and a
an actual map uh that you can get um
from travel and tourism that guides you
to various barns um that are in the
public domain um that can be viewed and
toured or might have an interpretive
panel outside of them so again this is
another another instance where you have
um volunteers doing good work um and
producing something for the betterment
of the state I I think um and we did
receive from um the Department of
Agriculture uh a
$3,000 uh Grant um that didn't go into
this fund uh it had to go through travel
and tourism to support that website and
printing of the barn tour map I mean it
sounds like a potentially interesting
tour uh but it looks like nobody has
donated in the last four years um is
there any way that we can uh I mean
you're saying there's a website where
somebody could but is there anything
else you think could be done to get
people they probably don't have the QR
code on the booklet right that's to to
to put money in this fund you know
because nobody El the the website may
not have a button either the new
Administration may have a more active
Department of
Agriculture and
always yeah so is can the website be
enhanced in a way that you know makes it
more obvious that people can donate and
and which is a great question we we have
been working closely with travel and
tourism to um to uh update that website
um landing page and to uh um I don't
believe we have a donation uh button on
that and that's certainly a would be a
great idea and this could be a place
where those monies could go it seems to
me like it's it it very well could be
successful because there's still plenty
of people that enjoy looking at
historical sites and
um it sounds interesting I mean I think
getting just directing eyeballs to that
point where they can donate I think you
know might work it's a great idea
okay yeah I I could call Lori Hara and
ask her about the
brochure um all right so we'll leave
this for now is that the consensus yes
yes okay all right next
one uh now we got the state
Library
101 page uh 10
yep and it's hidden under the name
automated information
systems yeah Michael can you put your
microphone on and and then you can give
a
summary uh my name is Michael yor I'm
the director of the division of
libraries also uh State
librarian excuse me you probably need to
pull that microphone closer to
you live York just just like the state
like
[Laughter]
new uh the State Library provides
services to the 234 public libraries in
the state
um 75% of our libraries are in
communities that that serve fewer than
7500 people so they are by
definition resource
challenged and so the State library for
many years has provided uh services that
can't be provided by anybody else in the
state inter Library loan is a key
element of this because many of our
libraries can't afford to purchase
materials and now we have the ability
with the phisticated automation systems
that we have to identify the Holdings of
all of these libraries so we have what's
known as a union catalog of Holdings
that has almost 3,000 records three
million records in it that identifies um
materials and who owns them we also
provide the transportation system that
moves materials from one to another uh
we often get the question why isn't all
of this stuff digitized well it's being
digitized but um uh people are still
primarily reading uh printed word on
paper and will for for a while but uh
for the time being we have lots of
libraries uh relying on that and that's
how that's why we built uh the New
Hampshire automated information system
known as Nas in
1984 part of that is that um there is a
provider that we use that has uh that
provides the metadata that's necessary
for these materials to go into for the
the information to go into this
automated information system uh so that
the libraries can find the materials and
as you can imagine that's not an
inexpensive uh service the last time we
replaced our automation system it cost
us $2.5 million
so we do charge for some
Services we don't charge for the
transportation of the materials for
example but if libraries want additional
records uh we charge them and that's
what this um dedicated fund is for uh
you can see that there was a large
expenditure in 20 and
21 that was because that's when we were
replacing our um system and putting in
in the new system I mentioned that that
cost us uh two uh $25
million so we do need this uh we we do
need this Fund in order to uh to take in
the funds that we get from the libraries
and to on occasion spend money for
services that the libraries
use well it doesn't look like you're
getting any funds from libraries right
there's been no income for three years
right it's down because of the
digitization of things we used to we
used to provide actual catalog cards to
to libraries and we don't do that
anymore so that's why the the service is
down there are very few libraries that
do that right but the revenue are you
saying money gets transferred from those
libraries or they were transferring
money to us for those cards but they
don't any they don't do that anymore I
see um so why
what were these big numbers allocations
from the general
fund um
no those were
um we also set up a
system
uh known as nay local and it was to help
the smaller libraries actually purchase
an automation system many of our
libraries were not able to do that um in
the Manchester area area all of the
libraries have their have a system but
in Errol they're challenged to try and
get an automation system so we set up
this additional service called nay local
which helped those libraries get that
and they had to to pay for it the
advantage was it was much cheaper for
them to do this through us than it was
for them to do it on their
own uh yes representative
Wy you already have a separate
appropriation for the State library is
that correct I think you're the head of
that yes so that's a separate
appropriation it's not included in
here correct not in not in this not in
this fund yeah so State library is still
alive and well and supported through
other Appropriations is that correct
correct we can use
more can't we all thank you
representative
J so I mean to me the obvious
question
is with no Revenue a balance down to
4,900 how can this fund continue to
operate well it's you're right it's it's
it has has diminished over time but
um I don't see any need to to to do away
with it just because the funds are low
we may have something that we'll need in
the future uh yeah I'm not suggesting
getting rid of it I'm just saying it's
it's going to become ineffective unless
there is unless you have a plan for how
new revenue is going to come into it and
one of the things that we are doing is
trying to bring more of the smaller
libraries into our organization that
helps them purchase an automation
system and how how do they get help
purchas where does that money come from
oh it comes from the the local community
okay we're providing the expertise that
they don't have quite frankly to
purchase that but the funds come from
the uh individual
communities we currently have 22
libraries that are part of this this
Consortium of libraries so if a new one
came along would the money they they
spend go into this fund and then you
would pay the vendor yes okay okay thank
but well I'm confused because if you
have 22 libraries now in this Consortium
why is revenue still
zero um because what we're paying for is
the initial cost to to set these up they
have to take their data and convert it
there's a cost associated with that they
have to make the initial payment to the
to the vendor for the training Etc that
goes on I mean we've gotten to a point
where we're not getting many more
libraries that's correct so uh we may
need to we may need to rethink this have
the 22 been in there for a while yes
okay so that's why there's no
new activity we set this up
in uh 2015 I
think so how I mean I guess I still
don't understand how you're going to get
new Revenue
well if we had another Library
joined there would be the need to to
provide them with
services and to con for instance to
convert their data it would cost them um
a certain amount for each record that
they need to convert into a m machine
readable format because many of these
libraries quite frankly had the
oldfashioned card
cataloges and now that data has to be
inverted and they can't do it and we
can't do it you usually have to hire the
the vendor will take care of that as
part so then you don't anticipate any
expenses no okay I guess I yeah I looked
at 20 22 and 23 and saw $50,000 in
expenses I thought how you know 5,000
left but if there's no additional
expenses right now you don't need
Revenue right just point okay are the
software maintenance expenses for Na AIS
just part of your regular budget for our
system they are yeah but for the systems
that we have helped for the libraries
that we've helped join our service they
take they take care of those directly to
the vendor directly to the vendor I see
all
right uh rep Senator rosan
you um does does the State library
system have
any relationship with the university
system libraries and the community
colleges are they part of the
databases well they are part of our
inter Library loan Network so for
example if
you if you go to the basement of our
library you'll see that we have a Depot
there for transferring materials from
one library to another and all of the
college libr
are in that
system so if Dartmouth is lending a book
to the Manchester City Library it comes
through
us and they also have the ability to go
onto our catalog and find out who owns
this there's
a there's not as close a relationship as
we would like with the uh with the
university system but they have a
different role than we do quite frankly
so who's who pays for the physical
transport of books from dth through the
State library to somebody in Hollis the
State Library primarily using our
federal
funds we receive about 1.5 million a
year from The Institute of Museum and
Library services this money is given to
us after we develop A Five-Year Plan
which they accept and then we use and
and a major component of our Five-Year
Plan for the last 25 years has been to
maintain this inter Library loan Network
because it's
critical to the citizens in New
Hampshire because of
the unique rural character of our state
we're we're a little different than a
lot of States
because through graduate school without
it what's that I wouldn't have gotten
through graduate school with them right
our state is a little different in terms
of Library Services CU we still have
independent libraries run by their own
Board of Trustees and their own
Administration it makes things a little
clunky it really is like Santa's
Workshop in the basement of the State
library on any given day with various
van drivers coming with their bins
putting things together putting things
away and they've really formed wonderful
relationship ship with the local
Librarians um because they know when the
van comes there they have the the books
that have been requested by their
patrons um but with with running that
process you get to understand a a little
bit about what readers in New Hampshire
are
into and I asked uh recently what what
are readers in New Hampshire looking for
right now and apparently it's Amish
romance I'll leave it at that
should we leave this one for another
five years and and if it becomes it no
activity at all then we'll get rid of it
does that make
sense if
someday if someday the technology
changes again they're going to need
that I suppose right but they'll
probably get a a capital budget uh
allocation rather than this but yeah who
knows
that make sense yeah we're happy all
right next one is uh 102 the next page
uh books damage
books lost lost and
damage uh this is this is a standard uh
practice of of all libraries um we're
more than will to lend materials to the
patrons in our
communities but we expect them to we
expect them to return them in as close
to the initial state that they took it
out as possible and when that doesn't
happen um I have to send a letter a
registered letter according to the
statutes uh it's against the law to
retain a library book longer than uh the
time that's been assigned to you um
uh we don't like to do this it's it's
not good public relations obviously um
but um we do have the the statute to
back us up that if somebody has not
returned a book and we've made a good
effort to try and get it back from them
that we can then charge them the cost of
the book and also the cost to process
that book to put back on the shelves and
that's why we have this uh damaged and
lost book uh account Senator gray the
way you work Ed that it sounded like you
didn't want to send certified letters
anymore I never like to send the
certified letters well certified letter
is probably going to cost you what four
to8 oh well I and I guess I misspoke I
don't mean a certified I mean uh a
letter that clearly indicates that we
know that they've still got the book um
so we send a letter to them and I cite
the statute uh that says they're not
permitted to to retain library books uh
unless we've authorized them uh to do so
and and then um most often we get the
books back um so that's why we have this
uh in place and as I say this is sort
this is a standard practice in in
library in the library um field uh to to
uh make people aware that they have to
pay for materials that they damage
so you've had a significant shortfall um
the last three of the last four
years um in terms of uh expenses
exceeding Revenue do you need to charge
more for these Lost Books than you
are well I think that could
be that could be for a couple of um a
number of reasons one being that um
people are better about returning books
or that um people are not borrowing as
much as they as they used to um we're
not really uh I always try to make it
clear we're not a public library our
collection doesn't
reflect uh the commissioner mentioned
Amish romances uh I don't I don't
believe I don't believe you'll find an
Amish romance in the New Hampshire State
Library collection what you will find
are the statutes you'll find all kinds
of material that supports state
government and information that we think
that the uh patrons and in this case the
citizens in the state of New Hampshire
would find uh interesting we don't have
a large uh medical collection obviously
um we don't have and we don't have a lot
of literature or uh uh novels uh you
won't find best sellers in our
collection
and candidly more people are getting
their materials through uh Amazon and
lots of other uh sources so I I think
that's um that's a reason why you would
find that our U uh our Revenue would be
down we're just not a we're not losing
as much as we've lost the it's not a
revenue issue it's it's it's just the
expenses seem quite fairly great right
so you you have Revenue of5 00 1,200
1300 but you've got expenses of 3,000
8,000 right
so if you had two more years like this
year the the B the fund will be
empty wait
see right again our purpose for for for
having this is just the mechanism to uh
put the money into a fund so that we can
use it to actually replace the book
yeah we don't think that that um if if
the and it could be that the book is not
going to be replaced either it can't be
because it's no longer available from a
a uh jobber uh or it's something that we
don't think fits with our collection
development policy or it's Antiquated in
some ways so
that so again we've set this up just so
that we can collect from representative
Jan again yeah I I'm just along that
same line of questioning obviously 2024
the expense is uh more than double what
it's been do you know what why that
jumped up to
8500 I I don't have an answer for that
rock the top of my
head it's just if you want to continue
to rely on this fund you might consider
charging
more or spending less you know one of
the
okay um we're not going to get rid of
this one so yeah we're happy all right
let's go on for the next
one
okay um there's one more Library one
when we do that one
um on page 19 of
36 donations and gifts
Family Resource connection genealogy and
talking book this is interesting right
the Family Resource connection no longer
exists um that was a a unit within the
State library that we set
up
um two in 2000 I believe
um and so it it's no longer there we
have an extensive genealogy collection
and we provide services to
the the term used to be the Blind and
Physically handicapped it's now the
print
disabled so um again we use this to uh
accept uh gifts that we get and talking
books um quite frankly receives a lot of
attention a lot of people rely on our
talking books service um we have about
2500 clients in New Hampshire and we're
doing most of the services of this type
for the blind uh and um print disabled
um and it's not uncommon I get letters
all the time from family members talking
about how important the service was uh
to their relative their father their
mother um and we have an absolutely
fabulous staff
you know somebody will call up
ostensively because they want to borrow
a book they want a book from we send
them a catalog and then we send them the
the
uh uh the flash drives these are all
provided by the Library of Congress the
service has been around for almost a
hundred years it started in the early
30s um and the
um so we will have people call up
ostensibly because they want to borrow a
book or they have a question but really
they just want to talk to somebody
because they haven't talked to their son
or daughter for a uh time so our staff
almost asks like counselors quite
frankly and they do an outstanding job
and so it's not unusual for us to get uh
named in people's Wills because they are
appreciative of the services that we've
provided um
the uh
talking book service in New Hampshire
has been in place for uh um 50
years and uh still going we have changed
with the times we're now using we
started off with vinyl discs um the
Library of Congress didn't go to uh CD
ROMs they
um they went to cassettes and didn't
change to the CD ROM uh what they
finally did was to develop a uh an
inexpensive way through um uh flash
drives to do this so talking books is
located up on the hospital grounds in
the dollop
building sounds like sen this may be one
for uh at least an update in the statute
you know so that you can take out your
family resources and other things so
let them do again because he's going to
know better than
you yeah why don't you look
ATS and
so let's go back to 103 I guess is that
the last
one
art m
M hi there Adele Sicilia I'm the
director for the the division of
Arts there you are
okay
yeah sure Cecilia s i
c i l i
a that's okay I'm sorry I
mean
gotta all
right so one half of 1% of the first $15
million goes to
Art right this seems Universal
everywhere I could tell you stories of
strange things that passed for art and
new airport is
gend know different cultures different
heritages yeah spending money on
everything so one of them was have these
frames that go from one to another yes
someone has these little Spinners on the
wall like they came out of a dryer or
something so when wind forced by the
train going forward spins these things
this is visual yes and as you drive up
to the airport the Mustang left a rusty
tractor oh there piles of
hey fence lines
art somebody paid money they've got a
Mustang out there too with like blue
illuminated eyes this yeah this is what
passes so to a good point um Adele can
can you remind us how um how we select
the artist for per for our what is our
role don't we involv the local community
and it it's a matter of committee
usually the developer certainly the
architect for the program city planner
if they choose to as well as uh
invitations to local community members
to contribute to what they feel is
reflective of their community and where
the art will be
placed
okay do an airport there's a lot of
money remember Logan some of the floors
walk yeah the the
yeah we'll see what plans Ted kitchens
has later then if they have to do a
renovation over there in
Manchester something to look at yeah
hopefully something to make you smile
you remembered right right
yeah yeah I'd like to get some new art
for our room down here I've been looking
at the same two ugly paintings for 12
years you know you're going to probably
have to talk to the State House
committee about them but also we do have
an art bank that offers a rotation of
five different pieces I looked at it
once but I I didn't care for the eight
choices or whatever were there anyways
all right so
this this this is strange because you're
only got re Revenue to of the past five
years I mean doesn't the state do more
construction than that seems like we do
construction all the time right so not
necessarily qualifying in that and they
may not need new pieces
depending on if there's existing ones
because if if we are using something
like that then we wouldn't need to
purchase or commission new works no no
but just Revenue isn't the revenue
supposed to be half a percent of the
first 15 million of of all construction
of a new building of a new building I
know I haven't thought about enforcing
it sure interesting but we're building
all the time aren't
we you never know some cement inlays can
always be possible
I mean we got the new parking garage
here right not yet what's that I was to
ask well what is that that's 10
million and is it the city or is it it's
a major addition all right anyways go
ahead than you
um are the artists
selected always new ham
artists or does some of the art
get commissioned or purchased from
almost always New Hampshire but I can't
say exclusively particularly over the
course of our history but that New
Hampshire artists are
prioritized for these sorts of things
thank
you so so you're regularly buying things
but you're very rarely getting new money
regularly B I'm sorry I didn't
understand you're regularly spending out
of this account
but but you're rarely getting new I mean
let's let's put it this way in the past
five years you've um spent
$75,000 more than you've
gotten right or something like that more
than
that cuz it started in 2020 at $244,000
and now you're down to
building I there was in there's like
municipal court buildings that might not
be that expensive Hillsboro County yeah
County court buildings um there was one
in Milford recently yeah there was also
the dam building oh the dam building
that was also didn't
build yeah in which case we wouldn't do
a percent for our
youth facility building is being paid
for with arpa
funds
so that wouldn't
qualify because it's not part of capital
budget there is a former art percent for
art piece in the sununu youth services
Detention
Center Yeah by to answer a question
Senator by Statute that the arpa funding
would not be eligible under this yeah
this is strictly
capital state
funding yeah but most of House Bill 25
you would think this would be part
of no do local schools
qualify no no no it's the city level or
local state government you know like
Portsmith has their own percent for art
for their own projects in Portsmith
all right well I'm going
to I'll ask um the comproller about
why why these revenue is is so
low are you allowed to yes you've got
repairs to pieces of art owned by the
state and there's a lot of work just in
in the State House been going
on uh spending
money on making the portraits look like
what they were when they
started how many more do we have go
through I want to leave by
4:30 okay I think we're getting
close all right so this one no
change right except I'm going to ask a
question
elsewhere
all next
one okay so we have 190 and 240 left and
oh and a couple more
so 190 firefighter Auto Parts Etc very
interesting
project got several for Connecticut
Lakes no just before Connecticut Lakes I
think we're talking about 190 on page 20
and I'm looking at Patrick and Brian
this is Bear
Brook yeah Supply Depot inventory
fund right so this is for the funding of
firefighting tools and equipment for
municipalities
have relationship with Excuse me the
towns to supply them with tools
firefighting goes also with the training
relationship that our Rangers have
withs yeah so that's that's basically
the purpose of it
and what's the source of
funds if I may that the source of the
way that this account is on the source
of funding is essentially
reimbursement um so in other words we we
carry this account for the purpose of
allow of making available to
municipalities the firefighting
equipment and other equipment they need
they go ahead and purchase it or they go
ahead and take it we build them for it
and then they reimburse
it
okay and you have it for sale at less
than they can just go to the vendor for
it's I believe it's at cost for
them yeah and the negative balances are
due to um selling things just before the
end of the year correct timing of
reimbursed yet yes
right but my my question is why can't
they simply go to the vendor and get the
equipment why is the state
involed
statutory um requirement it's somewhat
specialized equipment and I
think fhips
us
okay I mean do you bulk purchase these
things and therefore get a better deal
maybe I don't know if they both
purchased but um that is one of the
responsibilities of our Bear Brook so we
have a headquarters at Bear Brook State
Park and uh our site manager there works
with our buo chief of for fire
protection and they
based I see okay all right any other
questions no we're happy all right
number
29 oh sorry did we do not do 219 219 220
and 221 are all similar yeah all right
let's 2 219
yes all all three of these are funds
trust funds there is a principal
balance um the balances have
produced the Investments have produced a
lot of earnings over over the years we
were spending for quite a long time a
very limited amount to not exceed the
amount of what was being earned on the
fund um that in in recent years in the
last three or four years we've gone
ahead and leveraged the value of of the
earnings that were accured over a long
period of time and we have spent down a
substantial portion of that amount we
cannot go below the principal balance
for each of these funds all of which
support stewardship of the Connecticut
headquarters area um in their different
capacities as described um but we're at
a point where
we're we've spent a significant amount
down to the principal B balances we
cannot exceed those principal balances
um and at this time probably we'll be
finished by the end of the year with
most of the earnings that have been made
available um in the hopes that over time
they will continue to they will grow
through the investment and be made
available in the
future but these Pages make it look like
there is no balance why don't you sure
beginning
B well we don't
maintain I know and that's kind of
confusing
the the way that they're maintained on
the accounting books in in the state is
essentially they only show what is what
is spent and then what we draw from the
fund to pay back those expenses so it
essentially always looks like same in
same out which is which is essentially
what happens on the accounting books but
the trust fund statements themselves are
not published as part of the state's
accounting and therefore they're not
depicted in this document as such but I
can provide for you information on the
trust fund balances themselves showing
the principal amount the additional
amounts available and what is left to be
spent you did in all your other trust
funds you showed the value of the trust
yeah in the in the the case of those
trust well again we're not really
depicting the value of the trust fund
itself we're depicting the activity that
is available for spending against what
is available
yeah yeah the the many of the trust fund
accounts that are that are shown in this
document do not actually show the
principal balance that is that is being
used fundamentally to fund what you're
seeing
here yeah we we'd like these pages to be
more complete what I'm hearing is that
some other accounting system is holding
the balance of the fund and they're
transferring to you at the appropriate
time the interest the state treasury
maintains the funds which is consistent
with what we've done in other
things
yeah all right so yeah please make these
more complete or give get us the other
information so we'll leave these
open yeah okay representative Jan um I
guess yeah I'm I just have a question
about the fact that I understand you can
only spend as much as comes in but for
example in the last year 5600 came in
5600 got
expended I mean is that no we we're not
we're not limited to spending these
particular trust funds we're not limited
to spending only what has been earned on
the
funds for a period of time we were
limiting ourselves to that um but in the
last few years we have actually been
spending more than what has has been
earned on them because that those
earnings were accumulated over a long
period of time and are available for us
to spend we have found a need to invest
fairly heavily in a lot of the uh
maintenance needs that support the
Connecticut headquarters area and so
therefore we are leveraging that
accumulated balance that has been built
over many years that's why you see a
higher spending than so so in this case
where you only spent 5600 that's all you
really needed there's other money that
you could have pulled in you need to
spend more what I'd like to do is is
postpone the discussion of these three
until we have complete information and
then at our next meeting and ask them to
come back okay can we do that can I just
represent one governance question
endowments generally have uh a different
group in the background who gave the
endowment and is monitoring
it is that happening or in this case the
the endowments were established by
someone a giver and we are responsible
for um the treasury the state treasury
is respon responsible for the
stewardship of the fund of of the fund
itself we are the recipients of
the the money generated by the fund and
are able to use that so what you what we
depict is what we use how much we spend
and how much we
draw um but this does not contain
a full picture of the endowments
themselves and we can get that from the
treasury we can get that from the
treasury yes I can provide that for you
and you'll also know where the money
came from in the in the first place yes
we have the historical documents that
are the writeups that establish these
endowments yes okay all right good let's
go on to number
240 on page 26
uh native
plants natural heritage
fund yeah so This falls under the
division of forest and lands the um
natural heritage
Bureau uh is responsible for um
documenting uh rare threatened or
endangered species in the state it's
under the uh Native New Hampshire uh
Native Plant law and the revenue funds
that come into this account
are largely Chris correct me if I'm
wrong but they're largely from the data
check requests um basically every time
someone contacts um it actually goes
it's a through a partnership with the
Department of Environmental Services
when someone's doing a project either a
development or a forestry project they
put a request in for a data check which
our staff manages the database and it's
a if there's a hit in other words if
there's a a rare threatened or
endangered plant or animal and the
animals are the those the animals it
it's data that's kept by fish and game
but they sent it to us we manage the
same data for them if there is a hit if
there is a plant or an animal of concern
then then a fee is charged actually and
and there's a recommendations to how the
applicant should address the the um
presence of that plant or
animal
um so we have a full-time staff person a
data check environmental reviewer that
responds to these
inquiries and a portion of her salary is
covered by these um these
revenues and I'd like to just add that
we're trying to modernize this um whole
process as much as possible so that
we're not receiving paper money in the
mail um and we're working with Dees with
some help from arpa funds to improve our
online transaction ability um which is
also just good business for developers
and folks that um that don't want to
send a check in the mail um and so and
so with that conversation with Dees
about how do we set ourselves up for the
future um we are also talking about um
real aligning the fees um uh just to be
more appropriate with the current market
because they're very
outdated
okay representative Wy you got a
question yes
um I there the data checks on
produce because they're rare plants and
you don't want people to uh go and
trample on them um or take them on they
sometimes there will be one little
cluster of plants in a three diameter
circle mile diameter circle and um
you're towards the edge of that Circle
and so we then speaking for conservation
commissions we we then have to get the
developer to go back and and check it
out and bring us how many plants there
are next to that
area so I don't know and even the longed
bat which we always get and which we
have never
seen is is um on our show up when
there's a data check so I don't know if
the rest of the state has that same
thing but but um it is a very wide
Circle and so practically all developers
are going to end up paying some kind of
f yeah
so in every circumstance that I've
witnessed um the staff is trying really
hard to work with the developer to come
up with a solution and it's not we don't
have any legal Authority we don't our
staff person doesn't have a badge um but
uh in most
cases I think the
conversations um produce a a good
solution um because we don't want to be
um unreasonable in you know as a state
um but it's also really good to have
that awareness um so that there are some
decisions you can make to to prevent a
loss of a specific plant or animal um
but we really use it as a conversation
starter so if you're having a bad
experience please let me know because um
our our whole um customer service um
goals are to make sure that we're
working in concert with a developer and
not um
constructionist my Conservation
Commission is all in favor of more rigor
than you're actually using but it does
make it longer and harder so on some in
some cases particularly when you've
never we we love you on Barron
strawberries so since this fund has
essentially zero balance you're you're
spending whatever comes in is is there
is there a point in having this instead
of just having an accounting unit in
your
agency Excuse me yes so yeah this this
account accumulates again the the data
check fees that come in and the other
fees um we have been experiencing uh
maximizing every dollar going into that
account um we do have a person employed
um in fact we've actually been uh there
is some portion of their cost is also
subsidized by by federal money that that
helps to pay for that as well
um whether or not there's any wisdom to
Exterminating this dedicated fund
account and diverting to a more
centralized natural heritage Bureau
account I think that would be something
I'd want to discuss with director
Hackley and maybe understand a little
bit better what the implication of
something like that would
be yeah think about that and also
it looks as though because you're not
accumulating anything here that your
expenses are greater than your the fee
income are yes we've reached a we've
kind of crossed the line where the costs
have actually begun to exceed The
Collection which is again I think why
the Commissioners mentioned there is
going to be a need to raise fees which
are again are far outdated um so in the
meantime uh there is um help the federal
grants okay yeah all all
right represent is there any dat Data
Bank other than the state Data Bank that
would provide the information at the
level it needs to be provided by Statute
I'm not entirely sure of that I would
defer that uh question to director
Hackley yeah I I don't I don't know
exactly but I what I do know is that we
contract with a uh National if not
International uh organization called
nature
serve and they have an extensive
database that's um managed you know very
rigorously and uh we pay them a fee each
year we enter we provide them with data
but they also kick back data to us so
there's a there's a data sharing
relationship but they are you know this
is a these are highly trained ecologists
and botanists that are on the other end
of the the phone and on the other end of
email
um speaking with our staff almost daily
so I feel pretty confident we probably
have the most extensive connection to a
a database that we would
want okay all right our next one is
historic sites there are only two left
so number 290 starts at the bottom of
page
28 um so this one
has modest Revenue but essentially very
little and
expenses so the um historic sites is a
is a bureau with under the division of
Parks and Recreation uh this is like the
Wentworth coolage
Mansion uh nansen uh ski jump uh weeks
weeks uh State Park um Frost Farm
facilities like that uh that we uh that
that we manage the the intent for this
was set up is the um um to help um
isolate revenues that come in through
those facilities to stay dedicated to um
reserved for specifically for historic
sites so that they don't kind of get all
consumed within the greater Park fund um
and utilized for for for other sources
uh so that was that was the really the
um the reason that it was established
and um as you said you the the revenues
that come in are for tours and and
missions through those
facilities um and um our operating
budget for that is is is sort of
separate to um where these these
revenues are coming in so are you
planning are you trying to build up
because you're planning some kind of
project
or because you've gone from from 46 to
100 over the years
here I think that might show a a growing
interest in visiting our state historic
sites this fund is never going to supply
enough money to do all of the work
necessary to replace you know uh really
fragile wallpaper um but I do think that
there's an opportunity to double down on
this fund and to figure out some better
Revenue generating opportunities within
the historic sites themselves as Brian
said it was established so that they
don't get lost in the shuffle when we
are
prioritizing uh you know our resources
we're going to need life you know
life-saving resources bathrooms Etc and
these would just drop to the bottom so
long story short is I would you know
we're always brainstorming and trying to
figure out uh ways to uh grow support
for these historic sites because they're
always going to need a little extra
attention um
and this is
this is okay but I think we have room to
grow this account but if you have so
many sites there must be more
maintenance money somewhere else right I
mean this is you've only spent $2,000
over the last three years that's not
enough that's not enough um no we get
support through the state parks through
um con the Moose plate we we're allowed
to use some of that money to help with
that um Brian did you want to add and
well are there's a um a general ener
fund appropriation which is unique to
the state parks uh around
$400,000 to support uh primarily the
staff um of of the historic Bureau so we
have two uh staff uh in conquered uh in
headquarters that U facilitate and hire
train and supervise the the seasonal
staff who are the interpreters and um
guides um at and maintainers of these
other resources okay so this is more for
occasional
special expenses or something yeah so um
I'm guilty of creating this fund um so
uh back when the Bureau of historic
sites was created um it was taken away
from Parks the uh the division of parks
as a standalone under the commissioner
of dread and um Bob Odell Senator Odell
former Senator Odell and myself
recognized that there was no place to
put any Revenue generated from events or
donations or gifts and that sort of
thing so so this so um this was to as it
was mentioned earlier was to stop
comingling of of um those funds with the
park fund um the um there was a general
fund as as Brian uh just mentioned there
was a general fund um appropriation set
up um when the bureau was
created um and again under the
commissioner's office and that did
establish the administrative costs for
the fund uh moose plate appropriation is
usually around
$250,000 that goes directly to historic
sites as well as to maintain other
historic resources within the park
system um and um there's usually a
capital uh request made um in the
capital budget process uh by historic
sites and that has been successful in
the past um for various projects so
there is funding outside side of this
but as the commissioner noted um uh
we've always tried to uh look for other
ways to help fund and support those
sites whether through it could be a a
rental of a facility um say at week
State Park or or some other uh program
uh lecture program or events and that
sort of thing so yeah I mean I see the
use of having little bits of spare money
for you know the refriger Ator broke or
something you know that and that happens
frequently um yes a heating system or
something like that absolutely okay all
right other questions about
290 no we're good all right last one
358 page
31 Coastal
resilience of
Z Forest management oh
no have zero
activity I don't know there's no there's
no chart yeah so this one uh was created
only a few years ago it has never
actually
any okay it was
2019 yeah sounds all right all right
repeal where happened and I can think of
one senator is probably going to scream
oh well it's
inactive yeah
okay well so it'll pass 23 to one what
you're
saying all right any other business
before we adjourn you'll let us know
when you'd like us back to talk about
Connecticut lat yeah how about
um I was going to suggest uh the first
week in October
and obviously it doesn't have to be
everybody right
so uh October 2nd which is a
Wednesday is that a
[Music]
possibility whatever works for you I
think you probably need the and I don't
okay I don't I don't know what's that
you don't know it probably includes the
clerk and I don't know because uh
yesterday I lost my
paper uh
updator or my schedule your calendar yes
okay but I'm hoping to find it
again so in general do you prefer
morning or
afternoon
okay all right so you could do 10 or not
11 well it should be fairly short we got
three funds and then we'll just kind of
have a list of we plan to do this this
and this and talk it over kind yeah
talking it over might take a little bit
of time
yeah um
10:30 1030
whatever Wednesday o 10:30 October 2nd
okay all right good we got it okay thank
you all thank you